nous recevons aujourd'hui madame
Dominique Simonneau Contrôleur général
des lieux de privation de liberté pour
aborder tout particulièrement la
situation des prisons mais bien sûr pour
nous présenter par la même occasion son
rapport annuel d'activités publiées en
avril dernier pendant la période de
l'intérêt de législature et je précise
que vous êtes accompagné de Monsieur
André ferraille secrétaire général du
CGLPL nous sommes heureux de vous
accueillir tous les deux avant de donner
la parole madame la contrôleur général
je vous présenter les grandes lignes de
votre apport je tiens rappeler que la
commission des lois demeure très
attentive à la préservation de la
dignité des personnes privées de liberté
tout particulièrement aux conditions de
détention il y a pour cela un rapport
qui était rendu le 12 janvier dernier à
la commission d'enquête visant à
identifier les dysfonctionnements et les
manquements de la politique
pénitentiaire française dont notre
collègue Caroline Navali était
rapporteur avec Monsieur Philippe
Benassaya qui était le président
cette mission cette commission d'enquête
elle a confirmé combien cette vigilance
reste nécessaire ne serait-ce qu'à
raison d'être densité carcérale donc
vous allez certainement nous parler
densité carcéral qui est de 118% c'est à
dire 71 700 personnes détenues pour un
peu plus de 60 000 places
opérationnelles et avec une densité
carcérale qui est encore plus importante
dans les seules maisons d'arrêt donc
c'est pour cela que j'ai souhaité qu'on
fasse en plus de la diffusion de ce
rapport donc tous les collègues qui sont
présents aujourd'hui ont eu connaissance
en dépit du fait qu'il s'agit d'un
rapport de la précédente législature
qu'on fasse un déplacement au centre
pénitentiaire de Fresnes avant même de
vous recevoir ce déplacement il a eu
lieu le vendredi 14 octobre dernier une
visite qui a permis de faire le point
sur l'évolution des conditions des
tensions dans l'établissement de
constater les efforts entrepris en
matière de salubrité de conditions de
vie il y a déjà des travaux qui ont été
faits dans les cours de promenade sur la
réflexion de certaines cellules sur
l'accès individuel au sanitaire c'est
pas une une mince affaire il y a
toujours pas de douche dans un
cellulement pour ce qui concerne on a pu
le constater aussi
[Musique]
ou encore dans des locaux de détention
ou de garde à vue j'ai vous donner la
parole de tout de suite après quelques
questions mes collègues vous
interrogeront pour une durée de minutes
ils en ont désormais l'habitude moi je
voudrais que vous puissiez nous dresser
un bilan de l'application de vos
recommandations et ce qu'elles ont été
suivies dans quel délai avec quel taux
de
finalement de performance par rapport à
ce que vous aviez saviez exigé qu'est-ce
qui ne l'est pas encore assez et quel
établissement ont particulièrement
retenu votre attention j'avais une
attention particulière sur le centre de
Bedenac où vous étiez rendu notamment en
Charente-Maritime
si vous aviez des recommandations
particulières devant la commission des
lois et puis une note plus personnelle
puisque vous avez récemment fait une
visite au Centre Henri Labory 30 mai au
10 juin dernier c'est un centre
hospitalier d'établissement
psychiatrique qui est situé dans la
circonscription j'ai rejoint le conseil
de surveillance de cette établissement
comme milieu autorise la loi depuis la
loi d'avril 2021 et je voudrais
connaître l'état des recommandations que
vous avez faites et si elles ont été
d'ores et déjà reçus suivi ou corrigé
par l'établissement c'est un
établissement qui tient beaucoup à coeur
par la qualité de ses professionnels et
des gens qui qui travaillent voilà pour
cette longue introduction avant que mes
collègues ne vous interrogent à leur
tour vous avez la parole madame la
contrôleur général
merci monsieur le Président
merci de m'avoir invité de nous avoir
invité
c'est un peu émouvant d'habitude moi je
suis là-bas et je prends des notes je
sais pas si je manque d'habitude dans
l'exercice mais bon
que vous dire les prisons j'en parlerai
en dernier parce que
malgré les petits compliments que vous
avez glissé sur Fresnes je pense pas que
ce soit non on est très loin de l'idylle
c'est un endroit dont même le directeur
de la pénitentiaire dit que c'est une
verrue qu'il faudrait raser tellement
c'est franchement c'est ignoble
la dernière lettre que j'ai reçue de
Fresnes c'est un monsieur qui crie
au secours j'ai j apostrophe est des
cafards partout venez
franchement c'est atroce nos collègues
mes collègues qui visitent ces
établissements 15 jours par mois
franchement prennent en pleine figure 15
jours par mois une violence
très dure à encaisser parce que quand
m'a dit je vais trivial quand une de mes
collègues m'a dit j'en suis au troisième
gars qui me dit
je ne peux pas chier
parce que dans la cellule on est trois
donc j'attends que mes codes tenues
partent en promenade donc je ne vais
plus en promenade
un autre lui a dit
nous-même a écrit je mange de moins en
moins parce que comme ça j'ai vécu moi
et d'autres qui vous disent ben j'ai des
problèmes graves parce que je n'y arrive
plus donc c'est quand même
quand on pense qu'à à la prison de
Toulouse face un détenu à attraper la
leptospirose c'est-à-dire la maladie de
l'urine de rat parce que il a ramassé
étant indigent il a ramassé dans la cour
des mégots pour fumer
on est quand même obligé de se poser
quelques questions sur sur notre société
sans employer de grands mots c'est
vraiment
ce sont des endroits terrifiants bon les
prisons les maisons d'arrêt je veux dire
puisque la surpopulation
il existe que dans les maisons d'arrêt
donc
la dernière
qu'on a vu par exemple si je parle de la
finalement j'ai dit que je terminerai
sur le pesant je commence c'est pas
grave
la dernière que j'ai vu la commission de
sécurité a donné son accord pour un avis
favorable à la continuité de
l'exploitation mais en se basant sur le
nombre théorique de place et non sur le
nombre d'habitants de la prison une
prison dans laquelle il y a pas de
plaque chauffante parce que
l'électricité le système électrique ne
le permet pas et donc les détenus se
chauffent leur
café ce qu'ils sont à cuire sur ce qu'on
appelle des chauffettes c'est à dire
quatre tubes de concentré de tomates
vidées dans laquelle ils enroulent un
mouchoir
il pose une casserole sur 4 boîtes de
conserve ils mettent le feu à l'huile
et bon il faut trois quarts d'heure pour
chauffer sa dos et surtout vous entrez
dans la cellule c'est une odeur qui vous
prend à la gorge d'huile brûlée mais
surtout on se dit mais c'est pas
possible
ça va prendre feu c'est
et le feu le feu c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas rare quand on était à la
prison de Gradignan trois par cellules
je le rappelle il y a une cellule il y a
eu un incendie de cellules un incendie
volontaire on a retiré un mort et un
demi mort si je peux dire parce que je
n'ai pas de ses nouvelles mais aux
dernières nouvelles il allait très très
mal donc
c'est ça la surpopulation la
surpopulation c'est aussi
on a une obligation de soins par exemple
et bien on ne peut pas la respecter on
peut pas la respecter parce qu'il faut
trois mois pour voir le psychiatre on a
un abcès dentaire on se perce les dents
soi-même parce qu'il faut il y a pas des
scores pour vous accompagner chez le
dentiste
je sais pas comment décrire mieux il n'y
a pas d'activité puisque il y a pas
assez d'activités pour tout le monde
puisqu'il y a trop de monde pour les
activités il
tout est contraint le personnel parce
que on s'entretient énormément avec les
détenus mais énormément aussi avec le
personnel pénitentiaire les surveillants
la dernière fois que j'étais que j'y
étais et que j'étais en prison et
c'était à très peu de temps ils nous ont
confié ils ont dit nous on vit dans la
détresse la plus totale
à Gradignan
les surveillants nous ont dit moi
détenus je refuse de rentrer dans la
cellule
donc
et pourtant s'il détenus refuse de
rentrer tellement stimulant et moi j'ai
passé des heures dans ces cellules à
discuter avec les détenus et je peux
vous dire
c'est particulier moi j'étais juché sur
le frigidaire le réfrigérateur pardon on
avait installé une planche qui sert à
mettre le matelas au sol pour les
surélever un peu qui tient vous avez du
bien le voir pendant vos visites tout ça
c'est du brick et du broke
c'est dangereux c'est si ça prend feu on
tremble à l'idée que ça prenne feu parce
que si ça prend feu la nuit comme il y
avait par exemple à l'ouverture de
Toulouse c'est un surveillant pour 50
détenus on en est aujourd'hui à un
surveillant pour 140 détenus je sais pas
qui de nous accepterait de voir son
travail triplé comme ça mais ça n'est
pas possible ça n'est pas possible de
laisser et les détenus et les
surveillants dans cet état
tout ça pour vous dire que
on paye cher on paye 110 euros par jour
par détenus mais on paye 110 euros par
jour par détenus pour que les gens
ressortent de là pierre qui ne sont
entrées donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise c'est pas
économiquement ça ne tient pas non plus
si on fait ce calcul bête
évidemment quand on sort de trois mois
quatre mois là-dedans on se demande à
quoi ça a servi puisque si c'est pour
passer 22 heures sur 24 en cellule dans
les conditions que vous connaissez que
je viens de vous décrire vous sortez en
pire état
vous n'avez rien appris vous savez si
vous avez lu le formulable rapport du
Secours Catholique et d'Emmaüs sur la
prison dernière dernier barreau de
l'échelle sociale ben c'est sur la
pauvreté l'indigence sur le nombre
d'îles les traits en prison sur le
nombre de gens qui entrent qui ne savent
ni rien qui ressort et ça non plus parce
que et parfois pourtant il y a des
chances il y a des gens qui qui quand
ils ont la chance d'avoir accès à ses
activités et bien ressortent en bien
meilleur état et ça on le doit
au personnel pénitentiaires
au personnel
de l'éducation nationale sur laquelle
j'attire votre attention parce que
bientôt on a rendez-vous avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale pour
essayer de prôner un statut des profs
qui dépendent directement en fin que
l'éducation nationale s'implique dans
les prisons autrement par des
conventions de façon plus pérenne
parce que savez-vous que
les professeurs en prison ont les mêmes
vacances que les professeurs à
l'extérieur ce qui fait que quand un
adolescent est incarcéré au quartier
mineur en juin et bien si en septembre
il a pas eu une heure de cours c'est un
peu stupide quand on pense que
la prison ne fonctionne pas sur le
rythme des vacances scolaires et ce
serait bien que l'éducation nationale
face à un effort pour s'impliquer comme
l'a fait la santé en prison il y a bien
longtemps
et parviennent
un statut peut-être plus attractif et
puis peut-être avec
je sais pas comment il ferait pour pour
que les vacances soient comprises dans
ces
plus ces vacances scolaires c'est bête
en prison ça n'a pas de sens les
vacances scolaires
est-ce qu'il y a pas de vacances
ensuite pour vous dire que nous c'est
pas dire nous militons mais nous prenons
fermement la régulation carcérale je
sais que c'est pas trop dans l'air du
temps mais
tant mieux je sais mais j'en suis bien
contente mais
je peux vous dire qu'on a eu le grand
plaisir d'accueillir au contrôle général
une trentaine d'organisations syndicales
des personnes pénitentielles des
personnes à pénitentiaires des
magistrats des avocats des organisations
qui travaillent en prison toutes
les organisations qui peuvent rentrer en
prison et qui et qui travaillent
certaines à condamné les gens d'autres à
les en faire sortir et que tout à part
deux organisations
militent fermement pour la régulation
carcérale
enfin prône préconise son pour et ça a
été
une vraie moi j'avais un peu j'étais un
peu on était un peu anxieux avant mais
ça a été un vrai succès
on va disons qu'on a constitué à partir
de la groupe de travail qui avec donc
les syndicats de magistrats de directeur
de prison les surveillants viendront
plus tard parce qu'en ce moment ils sont
en pleine campagne électorale donc il
tenait pas tellement à venir à ce
moment-là mais enfin on a des rapports
très fréquents avec eux et ils viendront
plus tard quand les élections seront
passées
les organisations d'avocat
tous ceux qui travaillent en prison et
on s'est quitté sur le fait qu'on allait
se revoir en janvier
et on est en train de préparer le texte
qui
issue de ces de cette rencontre qui a
duré toute une journée et tous à peu
près 1000 litres pour prône la
régulation carcérale parce que ça ne
peut pas durer comme ça de quelques
façons de quelques façons qu'on le
prenne de quelques je pense que de
quelques bords politiques que l'on soit
peu importe parce que ce qui compte
c'est même pas je dirais même pas ne
parlons même pas d'humanisme puisque
c'est devenu presque une insulte ni de
droits de l'homme puisqu'on se fait
traiter de droite assez vite mais
parlons de même cyniquement voilà
quelqu'un rentre en prison il faut se
mettre dans la tête que
sauf à deux à quelques exceptions près
les détenus qui rentrent et bien ils en
sortiront et bien faisons en sorte
qu'ils en sortent le meilleur possible
c'est un calcul rien que économique pour
la société
un calcul rationnel pour la société et
donc voilà c'est je trouve vous savez
à Gradignan et à sace peut-être ce
problème sera
aborder et ça me va me permettre de
basculer sur un autre chant qui est
celui je peux pas être trop longue
descente de rétention mais il y a un
système que les surveillants appellent
les portes tournantes c'est-à-dire c'est
le trajet de environ un volet de 500
étrangers qui font le tour entre le la
prison et le centre de rétention
ils vont en centre de rétention et là
maintenant je bascule sur centre de
rétention mais ils vont en centre de
rétention par exemple il refuse le test
PCR il refuse d'augmenter dans l'avion
il retourne en prison ils prennent trois
mois de prison à la sortie de prison et
vendre dans le centre de rétention cela
est parfaitement assumé par le
gouvernement parce que ils ne tiennent
pas à ce que ces gens sortent du tout
euh et pour un prix que j'ose à peine de
qualifier d'énormes
et bien
la journée de rétention coûte un prix
dément alors que
malgré les efforts du gouvernement de ce
que j'ai entendu
un nombre infime des étrangers repas
faut se poser des questions là-dessus
et c'est pas qui ne reparte pas parce
que non pas parce que le gouvernement de
fait de multiplie pas les efforts
diplomatiques pour les faire réaccepter
par les pays d'accueil mais les pays
d'accueil ne sont pas dingue pourquoi
ils reprendraient ces gens-là pourquoi
il les reprendra en tout cas il les
refusent puis ça a obéit aussi à des
logiques diplomatiques
qui nous échappe
et donc on voit mal l'intérêt de la
rétention et ce qu'on ferait pas mieux
enfin bon c'est un autre sujet en tout
cas en rétention on ne trouve plus que
une majorité de sortes de prison
d'ailleurs la dernière fois que je suis
allée en rétention il y a des gars qui
s'accrochent à moi il me disaient une
dame faites quelque chose vous voulez
pas me faire retourner en prison la
détention c'était le paradis à côté de
la rétention
c'est dire parce que c'est un univers
extrêmement carcéral la rétention
et puis disons qu'il y a peu
s'il y a peu d'empathie de la part de
certaines franges
d'entre nous d'entre nous les citoyens
pour les prisonniers disons qu'il y en a
encore moins pour eux les étrangers en
centre de rétention et
je ne sais pas
comment vous dire que
c'était descente qui était prévu pour 15
jours
on y passe maintenant 90 jours
c'est un peu
l'enfer quand même ils ont pas tort les
gars qu'on voit là-dedans et pendant le
covid c'était une vision d'horreur parce
que on était tous masqués et on entrait
dans des salles communes ou on trouvait
50 types qui se frôlaient se
fréquentaient parlait et se refiler le
virus
il y a et je comprends pas la base
légale de la rétention même est en cause
puisque
vous savez que les étrangers doivent y
être le temps strictement nécessaire à
leur éloignement mais il n'y a pas
d'éloignement très très peu
d'éloignement
donc voilà c'est une question qui reste
posée qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour résoudre
ce problème
est-ce qu'on devrait pas intégrer les
étrangers qui travaillent qui qui payent
des impôts chez doux et qui sont les
plus faciles à attraper les plus faciles
à renvoyer
c'est ça qui est regrettable c'est
peut-être je ne sais pas enfin bon on en
reparlera certainement
je peux vous parler des centres
éducatifs fermés
qui est l'antige qui sont les antichards
de la prison j'aurais mieux fait de
commencer par ça avant les centres de
rétention mais comme j'étais sur les
enfin bon bref c'est pas grave
les centres éducatifs fermés ce sont des
structures très préoccupantes je vous le
dis parce que on y trouve le meilleur
comme le pire et quand c'est le pire je
peux vous dire qu'on a eu une expérience
cuisante n'est-ce pas Andrée il y a peu
on nous a fait visiter un centre
transformer extraordinaire on avait fait
un rapport catastrophique sur ce centre
on nous a invité un an plus tard à
visiter comme il avait changé tu me
frappes ah non
j'ai cru qu'il me disait ne dit rien
et en plus il y a un avantage c'est que
devant la commission des lois on peut
tout dire puisque vous avez ici devant
vous les représentants de la notion donc
c'est une expérience
on nous invite donc un an plus tard
avoir
à quel point la directrice était démenée
pour changer tout suivre toutes nos
recommandations et on arrive dans un
endroit
idyllique on déjeune avec les gamins il
nous avait préparé le déjeuner c'était
formidable il y avait même une salle de
détente avec un petit Bouddha de l'eau
qui fait du goutte à goutte des enfants
un endroit qui me fiche les jetons moi
mais disons que c'était c'était quand
même c'était l'endroit relax c'était
merveilleux on sort de là enchantée 4
jours plus tard je reçois un syndicat de
la PJJ qui me dit vous êtes fait avoir
parce que le centre il va fermer et
qu'est-ce qu'on apprend cette directrice
merveilleuse elle avait une relation
sexuelle avec un des enfants et le
centre a fermé et je me suis dit là mais
c'est
tout juste horrible
et donc et donc voilà
j'ai vu la directrice de la PJJ qui m'a
dit mais j'ai honte je suis morte de
honte c'est affreux bon mais on a
rencontré il y a moins paroxystique il y
a des endroits qui sont absolument
géniaux où il y a des il y a des il y a
des activités mais moi j'ai visité un
centre et là sans blaguer vraiment
formidable où les gamins étaient heureux
il y avait pas de mur il se barrait pas
c'est la première fois je me suis dit
mais c'est incroyable je vais me dire
tiens je mets à battre tous mes
présupposés et je me dis c'est dommage
que ces enfants restent pas plus
longtemps dans ce sens tellement il est
bien il y avait des ateliers du bois des
ateliers du métal il y avait un atelier
cuisine et puis surtout le centre avait
lié des relations avec la ville la
petite ville qui était à côté il servait
les repas à la maison de retraite les
enfants non mais ça fait il leur
fabriquer des tables des chaises dès
qu'il y avait un événement il
préparait le buffet enfin bon et puis il
y a des endroits qui sont abominables
des sève qui sont à fermer
voilà donc je suis ennuyé que le
gouvernement prévoit de multiplier leur
leur construction ou leur création parce
que souvent on en construit pas mais on
en crée
parce que je crois que le modèle n'est
pas du tout stabilisé
et puis pour ne pas être trop long je
vais passer la parole en référence sur
les sur les établissements
psychiatriques parce qu'il est très fort
sur le sujet
merci
donc sur les établissements de santé
mental
nous avons
poursuivi les constats qu'on faisait au
cours des années antérieures sur les
puisque c'est un domaine dans lequel peu
de choses à changer à l'exception d'une
évolution de systématique dont je vous
reparlerai les principaux constats sur
ces établissements
c'est d'abord une attrition progressive
mais de plus en plus grave depuis la
crise sanitaire du nombre des
psychiatres et du nombre des soignants
c'est-à-dire une véritable perte de
moyens des établissements de santé
mentale qui se traduit dans un grand
nombre d'établissements dans un
mouvement qui s'est amorcé en 2021 et
poursuivi en 2022 par des fermetures de
lit parfois des fermetures de lit en
nombre important et des fermetures de
lit dont on nous dit qu'elles sont
provisoires mais dont la réalité des
entretiens que nous avons avec les
directeurs d'établissements montrent
qu'elles sont provisoires mais sans
perspective de sans perspective de faim
de ce point de vue plusieurs sujets sont
en cause notamment la démographie
médicale en premier lieu quelquefois
mais de manière plus marginale des
questions de moyens parce que ce qui
manque véritablement dans les
établissements ce n'est pas le droit de
recruter ce ne sont pas les ressources
permettant de recruter c'est simplement
la ressource humaine elle-même
c'est-à-dire le manque de candidat pour
les emplois que ce soit par manque
d'attractivité des emplois ou simplement
par manque de personnes formées alors ça
quelques conséquences graves sur les
droits des patients
la première c'est que évidemment comme
la crise doit être toujours prise en
charge
la psychiatrie allège sa présence sur
les structures ouvertes et les moyens de
prévention ce qui a pour effet
d'augmenter le nombre des crises puisque
on a allégé la prévention
une augmentation du nombre des crises
conduit directement à une augmentation
du nombre des patients pris en soins
sans consentement et cette augmentation
est d'ailleurs facilité par le droit
puisque depuis les lois de 2011 et 2013
des procès du allégés de placement soin
sans consentement ont été institués et
ce sont ces sur ces procédures allégées
et exclusivement sur ses procédures
allégées que se fait la croissance très
importante du nombre des placements en
soins sont consentement de sorte que ça
nous conduit à dire que l'allègement des
procédures n'est pas forcément qu'une
bonne chose dans la mesure où il
facilite aussi l'adoption de mesure de
contraintes dans ce contexte les
établissements que nous visitons sont
dans des conditions matérielles dont le
moins qu'on puisse dire et qu'elles sont
très variables
très souvent les conditions matérielles
de la psychiatrie sont quand même
globalement plus satisfaisante que celle
des prisons il reste quelques quelques
hébergements en chambre hôtelière sans
sanitaire mais c'est tant à être de plus
en plus rare la question des chambres
partagées est également de plus en plus
rare et l'exiguité des établissements
psychiatriques est un problème qui ne se
pose vraiment que dans les
établissements de centre-ville à
singulièrement dans certains secteurs de
psychiatrie de Paris mais dans les
établissements de centre-ville ou dans
les secteurs de psychiatrie implantés
dans des hôpitaux généraux à partir du
moment où on a des établissements
spécialisés en psychiatrie généralement
les infrastructures sont correctement
organisées le troisième constat général
qu'on fait nos établissements de santé
mentale c'est encore une certaine
réticence à l'entrée du droit dans la
psychiatrie entrée du droit qui entre
avec qui est difficile sous deux aspects
premier aspect c'est celui de
l'information des patients très souvent
les patients sont informés sur leurs
droits de leur situation sur leur droit
de recours sur nos modes de vie par des
soignants et des soignants d'un grand
mâle à faire ça d'une part parce qu'ils
ne sont pas formés d'autre part parce
qu'ils comprennent avec beaucoup de
difficultés pourquoi ils auraient à
expliquer à des patients comment se
prémunir contre l'action de gens qui ne
veulent que leur bien et c'est quelque
chose c'est on place les soignants
devant une injonction paradoxale qu'il
ne faut pas négliger parce que
c'est très difficile pour un infirmier
qui prend en charge impatient de lui
dire voilà comment tu vas pouvoir te
protéger contre moi
c'est un exercice compliqué la deuxième
exercice compliqué et là j'en viens à la
réforme législative de
2022 c'est la question de l'entrée du
droit par la voie juridictionnelle
depuis 2016 le droit était entré dans le
contrôle des mesures le juge était entré
dans le contrôle des mesures de
placement aux soins sont consentement
pendant depuis 2013 depuis
2022 à la suite de vestissitudes dont
vous avez je pense le souvenir devant le
Conseil constitutionnel le gouvernement
a dû mettre en place un contrôle
juridictionnel des mesures d'isolement
et de contention c'est un contrôle qui
aujourd'hui se heurte à des difficultés
pratiques importantes la première étant
d'ailleurs la convergence des systèmes
d'information entre l'hôpital et la
juridiction puisque les délais
d'intervention de jeux sont extrêmement
courts donc l'intervention du juge n'est
possible dans les délais prévus par la
loi que s'il existe un flux
d'informations en temps réel
plus d'informations très souvent
n'existe pas ou existe mal donc il y a
vraiment ce problème de convergence de
circuit d'information qui est un
problème très important sans lequel se
recourt
ne pourra pas entrer dans les faits ne
sera pas possible de le mettre en place
en second lieu évidemment cette
difficulté
s'étend la question de l'agenda du
personnel et ce que je vous disais sur
la démographie médicale sur la
démographie infirmière en psychiatrie
plus la situation que nous connaissons
sur l'état de saturation des
juridictions fait que ce nouveau recours
a été vécu de part et d'autre comme une
charge de travail supplémentaire et donc
et pour le moment culturellement rejeté
je dirais de part et d'autre je veux
dire par là que les psychiatres se
demandent pourquoi on les a on les
encombre de ce recours et les juges se
demandent encore un peu ce qu'ils ont à
juger quand on les saisit sur ce point
néanmoins le CGLPL qui a été depuis
longtemps promoteur de ce contrôle
juridictionnel de l'isolement et de la
contention qui reste encore promoteur de
l'extension du contrôle juridictionnel à
quelques mesures qui lui échappent en
psychiatrie notamment le placement en
unité pour maladie difficiles ne peut
que souligner qu'il est nécessaire que
ce contrôle existe soit renforcé et que
ce contrôle juridictionnel soit
réellement vivant ce qui pour le moment
semble entrer dans les faits avec
beaucoup de difficultés
pour conclure je voudrais puisque j'ai
la parole répondre aux questions que
poser monsieur le Président Houlier sur
le suivi des recommandations Bédenac et
le centre hospitalier Labori
globalement sur le suivi des
recommandations
il faut savoir que les recommandations
de CGLPL sont très nombreuses si les uns
ou les autres d'entre vous ont lu un
rapport vous pouvez voir dans dans un de
nos rapports de visite les visites étant
longues nous voyons les établissements
dans le détail et il n'est pas rare que
des rapports comprennent plus de 50
recommandations donc le suivi de nos
recommandations est un exercice que nous
ne faisons pas de nous-mêmes c'est un
exercice que nous faisons de manière
déclarative en interrogeant le
gouvernement donc les chiffres que je
vais vous donner sont à prendre avec la
précaution qui s'impose parce que quand
nous retournons dans les établissements
c'est-à-dire le suivi des
recommandations déclaratifs fait au bout
de trois ans quand nous retournons dans
les établissements c'est dans un délai
beaucoup plus long puisque nous faisons
beaucoup de visites mais pas assez pour
y aller tous les trois ans non plus et
donc pour le suivi
de ces recommandations en gros suivant
ça varie suivant qu'on est en
psychiatrie en prison ou en rétention
administrative mais il y a plus d'un
tiers de nos recommandations qui sont
déclarés suivis des faits environ un
cinquième c'est à dire un peu moins de
20% qui sont déclarés sans suite et
le reste c'est à dire à peu près 40 %
aussi qui sont déclarés partiellement
suivi alors on est vraiment dans du
déclaratif pour nous l'ambition que nous
avons derrière ce suivi des
recommandations ce n'est pas tellement
de connaître des chiffres ce n'est même
pas tellement devoir progresser ces
chiffres parce que nous ne sommes pas
tout à fait certains de la vérité qui
est derrière mais notre ambition réelle
c'est de faire en sorte que les services
de contrôle interne de l'administration
c'est à dire l'inspection générale de la
justice la mission de contrôle interne
de la pénitentiaire les inspections des
agences régionales de santé l'inspection
générale de la police intègre
recommandations et intègre le suivi de
nos recommandations au suivi qu'ils font
de leur propre recommandations quand ils
vont dans les établissements c'est à
dire que notre ambition première c'est
de faire en sorte que nos
recommandations entre dans les
référentiels de contrôle interne des
administrations et ceci je dois dire
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne assez
bien
quand je dis que ça fonctionne c'est pas
que c'est bien fait ça veut dire que le
processus est le processus d'intégration
est en marche
ça fonctionne assez bien puisque
maintenant dans l'administration
pénitentiaire la mission de contrôle
interne quand elle contrôle un
établissement contrôle ce qu'elle a
recommandé elle-même ce qui a été
recommandé par l'Inspection générale de
la justice et ce qui a été recommandé
par le CGLPL et c'est d'ailleurs la
mission de contrôle interne de la
direction d'administration pénitentiaire
qui est chargée de nous répondre tous
les trois enfin tous les ans au suivi
des recommandations faites trois ans
avant alors le cas de b2nac est un cas
particulier puisque c'est un cas sur
lequel nous avons fait des
recommandations en urgence
pour le coup quand nous faisons des
recommandations en urgence nous nous
comptons pas en principe d'un suivi
déclaratif nous retournons voir sur
place sur bedonnax ça n'a pas encore été
fait ça va l'être les recommandations en
urgence de Bédenac doivent avoir à peu
près 18 mois le cas de Bédenac était un
cas très particulier puisque c'est un
cas une situation d'un centre de
détention dans lequel il y a des
patients des détenus qui sont également
des patients dépendants qui pour des
raisons judiciaires ou pour des raisons
de difficultés de placement de sortie ne
sont pas de bénéficient pas de
suspension de peine pour raison médicale
et reste à la charge de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui je le dis avec
insistance n'est pas organisée pour
prendre en charge des patients
dépendants et donc l'administration
pénitentiaire avait donné a fait ce
qu'elle a pu assez bien
mais toute seule
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas eu le
soutien des deux institutions qui
auraient dû la soutenir d'une part le
système sanitaire d'autre part l'aide
sociale qui relève du département et
donc nous avons trouvé des patients
grabataires parfois en situation
d'obésité très grave que
l'administration pénitentiaire n'était
pas en mesure tout simplement de sortir
de leur lit y compris quand ils étaient
souillés donc c'est une situation
extrêmement grave et c'est une un
établissement dans lequel nous sommes
maintenant à moins de deux ans de la
visite mais nous allons prochainement
retourner pour voir pour constater
nous-mêmes ce qui a été fait comme nous
le faisons habituellement quand nous le
faisons des recommandations en urgence
en ce qui concerne le centre hospitalier
la Boris c'est une situation tout à fait
différente
c'est d'abord c'est une c'est un état
une visite que nous avons fait très
récemment puisqu'elle date du mois de
juin ce qui veut dire que
l'établissement n'a pas encore reçu le
rapport provisoire que nous lui aidera
au titre de la procédure contradictoire
donc je peux pas
dire ici ce qui sera dans ce rapport qui
n'est pas fini en revanche je peux faire
état des premières impressions que
l'équipe que l'équipe a retiré de cette
de cette visite le centre hospitalier
Labori est un établissement
psychiatrique que je qualifierais d'un
peu comme un autre
plutôt un peu mieux qu'un autre pas
c'est un établissement dans lequel on
rencontre les difficultés à ses
habituelles que l'on rencontre en
psychiatrie c'est un établissement qui
bénéficie de la présence d'une
université avec des professeurs
d'université donc très capé à sa tête
donc c'est un établissement que plutôt
bien tenu dans lequel les droits des
patients sont respectés même si la prise
en compte de la dimension juridique de
la prise en charge n'est pas toujours
n'est pas toujours optimale mais enfin
les rarement donc il y avait des
recommandé il y aura des recommandations
je pense là-dessus des recommandations
également sur le mode de calcul et la
politique de réduction du recours à
l'isolement et de la contention mais en
tout cas ne vont pas dans cet
établissement que je sache et sous
réserve de ce qui sera dans le rapport
provisoire relever d'atteinte grave au
datames graves aux droits des patients
pris en charge
merci pour ce propos introductif j'ai
donné la parole aux orateurs successifs
madame Caroline Labadie
monsieur le Président Madame la
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté vous avez dressé
avec la sincérité et la sensibilité que
vous ne connaissons la réalité de la vie
en détention liée étroitement d'ailleurs
au conditions de travail des
surveillants
139% taux d'occupation maison d'arrêt
1830 matelas au sol Raffard que nous
voyons aussi lors de nos visites cette
réalité saute aux yeux c'est pour
l'améliorer d'ailleurs que dès 2017 nous
donnions à l'administration
pénitentiaire des moyens sans précédent
le plan 15000 places qui en réalité est
un plan 18 places permettra de fermer
3000 places trophées nous avons doublé
le budget dédié à l'entretien du parc
immobilier vieillissant vous le savez
120 établissements date d'avant 1920 en
même temps nous avons essayé de limiter
les courte peines désociabilisantes leur
préférée des alternatives qui sont
parfois plus contraignantes je sais que
vous mesurez alors juste valeur ces
efforts et vous savez que nous ne nous
satisfaisons pas des résultats
aller plus loin pourquoi pas aller plus
loin que la libération sous contrainte
qui prend effet en janvier 2023 pourquoi
pas puisque désormais la palette des
outils offertes au juge est complète
mais sous quel modèle
ceci posait si nos points de vue divers
de par la nature même de nos missions
nous regardons dans la même direction
réinsérer ces délinquants pour diminuer
la récidive la prison punie et surveille
la prison réinsère aussi cette mission
d'administration pénitentiaire est
récente et visiblement encore méconnu
quand vous avez 75% de détenus dont le
niveau d'éducation est inférieur au cap
il faut former autre réalité qui saute
aux yeux la sur-reprétation en détention
des conduites addictives
trouver un logement un travail renouer
avec sa famille et ses enfants sont
aussi de puissants leviers pour la
réinsertion et lutter contre la récidive
notre combat commun madame la CGL il est
bien sûr d'agir contre la surpopulation
mais aussi de faire connaître le relais
essentiel que joue les professionnels de
l'insertion aussi une simple question
comment faudrait-il faire connaître et
faire sauter aux yeux cette réalité de
la du rôle de l'insertion en détention
merci
le président la contrôleur général les
prisons des lieux de privation de
liberté vraiment
si cela n'était pas un sujet si sérieux
cela prêterait à rire notamment après
les récences événements à Fresnes qu'il
s'agisse du karting de la piscine de
l'album de rap en préparation comme si
on était à Star Academy la prolifération
des téléphones portables des drones qui
atterrissent tranquillement dans la
prison pour faire des livraisons ou
encore des trafics en tout genre l'image
que les prisons françaises renvoient une
insulte une insulte aux victimes et à
leur famille nous avons madame la
contrôleur beaucoup de divergences de
points de vue et c'est peu de lire
l'idéologie gauchisante laxiste et 68
hard dans laquelle vous vous inscrivez
est en partie responsable de la
catastrophe sécuritaire que subit notre
pays cette idéologie qui vous habite ne
fait doute pour personne en effet au
moment de votre nomination vous avez
reçu les chaleureuses félicitations d'un
député de la France insoumise et dans la
foulée vous avez bénéficié d'un
magnifique papier dans le journal
militant l'humanité CQFD pour lutter
contre la surpopulation carcérale vous
préconisez une mesure radicale les vider
nous de notre côté nous comment créer
des places de prison comme 86% des
Français nous souhaitons expulser les
désincences étrangers qui représentent
environ 25% des détenus pendant le covid
vous avez salué le fait que plus de
10000 détenus étaient libérés nous nous
avons jugé cette décision irresponsable
vous soutenez le recours au Pen
alternatif les libérations anticipées et
la non-application du code pénal madame
la contrôleur j'ai bien écouté votre
propre inconnue introductif à aucun
moment vous n'avez eu un mot pour les
victimes sans surprise vous ne pensez
qu'aux détenus et à leur bien-être alors
madame la contrôleur ne pensez-vous pas
qu'au moment où toute la chaîne
pénitentiaire réclame plus de moyens ne
pensez-vous pas que vos 12000 euros de
salaire mensuel c'est ce que j'ai trouvé
sur internet non sans difficulté mais
peut-être que vous pourrez nous
confirmer cette information ne
pensez-vous pas que votre salaire
mensuel et les 5,3 millions d'euros à
louer annuellement à votre autorité
administrative indépendante ne serait
pas plus utile si ils étaient transférés
au budget consacré au recrutement
d'agent pénitentiaire à la construction
de places de prison
c'est tellement dommage que vous ne
soyez pas venu vous et votre groupe à
Fresnes visiter et justement monsieur le
Président
je n'avais pas la parole enfin vous nous
attaque je vous ai pas donné la parole
c'est très clair là-dessus donc vous
n'êtes pas venu à la prison de Fresnes
parce que vous ne voulez pas avoir la
réalité carcérale parce que vous ne pas
avoir ce que sont les conditions dans
cellulement qui ne sont pas des
enseignement individuel qui ne répondent
pas à ce que finalement on pourrait
attendre de la dignité humaine vous
n'avez pas vu les efforts qui sont faits
par le directeur qui pour le coup est un
homme formidable avec tous les moyens
qu'il met en oeuvre pour les détenus
donc ce genre de propos non mesuré c'est
tellement dommage que vous le teniez
devant notre commission ensuite ce que
vous avez déclaré sur sur la aïe c'est
quelque chose que vous votez
chaque année c'est quelque chose que
nous n'avons examiné également dans les
budgets du ministère de la justice et
dans les budgets je ne vous ai pas vu
déposer l'amendement sur ce sujet comme
je ne vous ai pas vu contester hier
devant le garde des sceaux toute une
série de choses que vous venez de
déclarer ici donc vous êtes libre de vos
propos et je suis libre de vous dire ce
que j'en pense compte tenu des actes qui
sont les vôtres monsieur
merci monsieur le Président oui je
recommande à tous les collègues et
d'ailleurs en dehors de la commission
des lois aussi de visiter les lieux de
privation de liberté et tous de la garde
à vue centre de rétention administratif
en passant par les centres éducatifs
fermés les prisons étant un des un des
éléments de ces lieux de privation de
liberté moi j'ai une question enfin j'ai
trois trois questions pardon trois très
courtes questions madame la contrôleur
général
on a on a parlé vous avez évoqué vous
même la question du mécanisme de
régulation carcéral pour éviter la
surpopulation et faire en sorte qu'on
puisse enfin faire un travail à peu près
correct à peu près correct dans un
premier temps en prison et d'ailleurs
tous les surveillants pénitentiaires
quand j'ai visité des lieux de privation
liberté pendant le covid était des
personnes heureuses parce que pour la
première fois on était pas 150% de taux
d'occupation mais plutôt à 115 110 et
j'ai vu des gens épanouis parce qu'il
retrouvait du temps pour échanger avec
avec les personnes détenues pour faire
un suivi plus plus
encore plus précis et bon alors pour les
activités il fallait repasser parce que
pendant le covid précisément il y avait
plus non plus d'activités mais enfin on
voit bien que la surpopulation est
quelque chose qui empêche le travail
correct en détention et la réinsertion
ça vient ma deuxième question est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner votre sentiment
sur le la pré polémique Koh-Lanta c'est
et le karting à Fresnes on a vu que il y
avait eu des circulaires qui avaient été
prises par le garde des sceaux pour
obliger les directeurs à faire remonter
pour validation les activités ce que
vous avez vu constater quelque chose des
conséquences de tout cela pour l'instant
et dernier point j'aimerais avoir votre
votre avis sur la question de l'accès à
Internet en prison on a franchi déjà une
belle étape avec le téléphone en cellule
qui était très décrié par les Amis de de
l'extrême droite donc plus personne ne
n'a rien à dire aujourd'hui si ce n'est
que ça apaiser les tensions et que ça
permet que ça se passe mieux en
détention pour tout le monde on est
surveillant et les personnes détenues
monsieur Éric Poget
oui merci président madame la Contrôleur
général des lieux de privation liberté
d'abord permettez-moi de vous dire que
je ne partage pas votre vision sur la
régulation carcérale c'est à mon avis un
des
sujets qui créent cette défiance dans la
société je dis pas que la solution est
facile mais on aurait pu attendre de
votre part une demande de moyen
supplémentaire pour nos prisons en tout
cas cette vision sur la régulation
carcérale est un des sujets dans notre
société aujourd'hui moi je voudrais vous
interroger plus particulièrement sur les
centres de rétention administratifs vous
en avez vous avez évoqué le sujet il y a
un certain nombre de places qui vont
être livrés dans les prochains mois mais
on sait qu'à fin 2023 on va arriver à
2000-2100 places or il y a à peu près
120 000 au qtf prononcés chaque année
quel est votre vision sur ces centres de
rétention administrative ne faut-il pas
beaucoup plus de moyens faut-il pas
envisager d'autres moyens de rétention
via notamment les bracelets
électroniques j'aimerais voir votre
sentiment et votre avis sur ce sujet
merci
monsieur Iron Man
madame la contrôleur des lieux de
privation de liberté c'est à nouveau
avec plaisir et intérêt que nous
accueillons dans cette audition comme à
chaque fois notre groupe va aborder
certains champs de votre action avec
franchise objectifs et humanité
alors la France est l'un des trois pays
européens recourant à la rétention
d'enfants mineurs accompagné la France
contre vient à ses obligations
internationales surtout elles
controvient au respect de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant protégé par la
Convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant et garantie par la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme c'est
ainsi que le 31 mars dernier la CEDH a
condamné la France pour avoir placé en
rétention administrative un enfant
georgien de 8 ans ainsi que ses parents
durant 14 jours avant leur renvoi dans
leur pays elle a considéré que ce
placement ainsi que la durée constituait
des traitements inhumains et dégradants
pour cet enfant au regard de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ce n'est donc pas la première
fois que nous tirons la solette d'alarme
de fait à chaque condamnation de la
France le Défenseur des droits réitère
son opposition placement de ses enfants
et nous exhorte législateur ainsi que le
gouvernement à faire évoluer la
législation pour proscrire en toutes
circonstances cette mesure j'ai moi
aussi porté Elodie et Jacquet forge qui
est à côté de moi portez ce sujet lors
de la précédente une signature et
plaider pour son interdiction vous
recommandez la mise en oeuvre de mesure
d'assignation résidence des familles
plutôt qu'un placement ancra et des
instructions étaient adressées au préfet
dans ce sens la protection de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant doit être assuré
en toute circonstance mais question sont
les suivantes pourriez-vous nous
indiquer dans quelle mesure cette
assignation à résidence est prononcée
par rapport au placement en rétention et
à défaut d'avoir encore pu interdire les
placements rétention pourrez-vous
pourriez-vous nous dire de quels moyens
peuvent manquer les préfectures pour
généraliser les assignations à résidence
et de quelle manière nous pouvons les
inciter à privilégier cette mesure je
vous remercie je me suis arrivé Solignac
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
madame la contrôleur général Monsieur le
Secrétaire général revenir sur la
question de la santé mentale et des
établissements psychiatriques que vous
avez évoqué avec une certaine précision
non sans rappeler que vous avez beaucoup
alerté pendant la période du covid sur
les restrictions en matière de liberté
de déplacement ne serait-ce que d'accès
à la cafétéria pour les patients qui
étaient en établissement etc etc
dans votre propos vous avez évoqué les
fermetures de lit en établissement
psychiatrique et depuis assez longtemps
maintenant même plusieurs dizaines
d'années le modèle est à moins
d'hospitalisation et plus de soins au
domicile selon des modalités qui sont
différentes
et qui reçoivent par conséquent qui font
l'objet d'un suivi par conséquent
ambulatoire ça serait près de 2 millions
de Français qui seraient atteint de
troubles psychiques ou psychiatriques et
qui serrait suivi de cette façon là ils
ont incontestablement gagné en liberté
et en autonomie et ça évidemment c'est
une bonne chose et dont certains qu'ils
ont gagné en soins parce que vous avez
beaucoup évoqué le manque de personnel
de moyens humains et matériels
c'est ma première question est-ce qu'on
a pas désengorgé les hôpitaux sans se
donner les moyens de de de garantir un
suivi à domicile de qualité et puis ma
deuxième question mais qui est
directement liée à ma à ma première
et qui concerne ce manque de moyens
matériels et humains on observerait un
certain nombre de départs volontaires de
la part de médecins psychiatre qui
travaille en établissement et qui sont
soit en désaccord avec les procédures
soit dans une situation professionnelle
extrêmement compliquée et qui croule
sous la charge de travail quand il est
vrai que les exigences notamment
administratives de suivi des patients
qui pèsent sur eux sont assez complexes
à
satisfaire donc est-ce que vous avez
observé ces départs volontaires de
médecins psychiatre en établissement je
vous remercie Monsieur Philippe trabala
madame la contrôleur général des gosses
privations liberté monsieur le Président
chers collègues je tiens tout d'abord
madame à vous remercier pour votre
exposé votre investissement dans la
mission qui vous a été confiée et 124
visites d'établissements effectuées en
2021 en témoigne la lecture des
différents rapports publiés par votre
institution des fins un tableau assez
alarmants de l'état de nos lieux de
privation de liberté cela a été dit il
est question d'infrastructure de moyens
humains mais également de politique
pénale d'incarcération la question de la
surpopulation au sein des maisons
d'arrêts est au cœur de cette
problématique à ce titre la
circonscription que je représente ne
fait pas exception avec un taux
d'occupation de 151% à la maison d'arrêt
de Nice vous n'êtes pas en savoir que
notre assemblée est en pleine période
d'examen du budget pour 2023 nous avons
auditionné hier Monsieur Eric
Dupont-Moretti au sujet du budget de son
ministère celui-ci prévoit notamment la
construction de Casus place nette de
prison supplémentaire d'ici 2027 la
rénovation et la modernisation du parc
pénitentiaire existant avec une dotation
de 130 millions d'euros un budget inédit
dans la matière
cela s'accompagne d'une amplification
des efforts consacrés aux aménagements
de peine mesures alternatives à
l'incarcération avec 28 millions d'euros
consacrés aux mesures liées à la
surveillance électronique 11,5 millions
au bracelet anti rapprochement et très,9
millions au placement à l'extérieur ce
budget nous sommes ciblés de manière
pertinente à certain nombre de
problématiques que vous soulevez mais
cela doit s'accompagner d'autres mesures
notamment en matière de politique pénale
vous avez suggéré à plusieurs reprises
dans vos rapports et prises de parole
que soit prévu dans la loi un dispositif
de régulation carcérale institué en dans
chaque juridiction un examen périodique
de la situation de la population pénale
ce sera donc l'objet de ma question si
l'idée le concept semble louable il
existe une interrogation sur la mise en
oeuvre pratique j'apprécierai donc vous
puissiez nous exposer quels sont les
grandes lignes que vous pensez pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre que devrait contenir la
loi sur des critères permettant de
mettre en place cette politique de
régulation carcérale
madame la contre-leur général des lieux
de privation de liberté monsieur le
Président je souhaitais vous interroger
sur les mesures prises en faveur du
travail
tu travailles et de la réinsertion dans
votre rapport annuel de 2021 vous saluez
les avancées issues de la loi du 22
décembre 2021
même si elle ne fait pas entrer
totalement le droit du travail en prison
vous avez une formule tout en retenue
que j'ai relevé dans votre rapport vous
dites on peut certes au nom du réalisme
s'accommoder du caractère modéré de
l'avancée ainsi réalisé on parle des
contrats d'emploi pénitentiaire mais
pour être acceptable une telle
modération ne devra pas être excessive
notamment au regard du niveau de
rémunération et des règles relatives à
la durée du travail
en effet les personnes détenues restent
sous-payés et notamment privé de tout
droit collectif le gouvernement vient de
compléter cette réforme par une
ordonnance du 19 octobre qui ouvre de
nouveaux droits sociaux pour les détenus
qui travaillent aussi je voulais vous
poser la question regarde c'est avancées
qu'elles
appréciation vous avez sur sur l'état du
droit merci
madame Emeline cabilly
je voulais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour le travail que vous avez accompli
que vous continuez d'accomplir et qui
nous donne une une vision
particulièrement claire même si elle
était effrayante la plupart du temps des
conditions de détention et de rétention
ma question concerne plus
particulièrement
donc elle concerne les outre-mer et
notamment le centre les centres de
rétention administrative de la Réunion
et de Mayotte où les conditions sont
particulièrement indignes
Mayotte et la Réunion concentre plus de
la moitié des des retenus de France dans
des conditions qui ont été dénoncées à
plusieurs reprises par vous mais
également par d'autres associations La
Cimade notamment à la Réunion on a un
centre de rétention qui ne compte que 6
places et nous sommes confrontés de par
notre positionnement géographique avec
Mayotte un nombre important de personnes
retenues on a depuis quelques mois
maintenant un phénomène nouveau avec des
vagues migratoires venus du Sri Lanka et
qui rendent des conditions de rétention
encore plus indignes parce que dans avec
6 places on ne peut pas recevoir les
gens dans des conditions correctes alors
je ne suis pas favorable bien évidemment
à ce que l'on crée de nouveaux centres
de rétention est-ce que l'on les
augmente ou nous avaient donné quelques
pistes mais ça crée des situations qui
sont particulièrement inquiétantes
on a été alerté rien que que cette année
en février 2022 on a eu un homme qui a
été qui a passé 10 jours en centre de
rétention sans pouvoir voir un juge on a
au mois de mai un français qui a été
enfermé en centre de rétention et qui
n'a pu être libéré tardivement et au
mois de septembre des Sri Lankais
numérotées en centre de rétention je
voulais avoir vos préconisations sur
cette situation inquiétante monsieur
Jean-Philippe
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
contrôleur bonjour Merci pour votre
exposé et pour le travail que vous
réalisez en ce qui me concerne ma
question sera précise
le 2 mars dernier mot de passe en savoir
qu'il s'est passé un drame important
dans la centrale d'Arles puisque un
détenu donc radicalisés apportés
atteinte à Yvan Cologne et que suite au
coma celui-ci est décédé cela est créé
beaucoup des mois en Corse mais pas
simplement y compris au sein de cette
commission des lois
donc à ce stade je voulais simplement et
de manière très très simple savoir
savoir un petit peu votre vision et
votre votre vision votre point de vue
sur sur la gestion du parcours du détenu
en question puisque beaucoup d'arguments
ont été exposés devant cette commission
pour justifier le fait que se détenus ne
puisse pas aller en guerre en quartier
d'évaluation de la radicalisation
mais aussi mais aussi plus globalement
sur la gestion du statut de détenus
particulièrement surveillés de manière
générale et en particulier dans dans ce
cas là votre point de vue est important
dans la mesure où prochainement il y
aura très certainement comme si on
enquête parlementaire qui qui se
penchera sur sur ce qui s'est passé donc
merci pour vos réponses par avance
merci Madame la contrôleur général pour
vos réponses à ses premières questions
alors je réponds d'abord à Caroline
Abadie je crois
et bien effectivement il y a des efforts
faits sur le budget il y a des efforts
qui portent sur de nouvelles places de
prison bien que
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un un jour
m'explique
ce que sont ces 15000 places de prison
promise de mandatures présidentielles en
mandatures présidentiel
je vous avoue que j'ai du mal à m'y
retrouver c'est toujours 15000 places
qu'on nous annonce et c'est jamais que
15000 places auxquelles on aboutit donc
je crois que les présidents successifs
reprennent les 15000 places du précédent
et puis l'améliore de 2000 places et
puis enfin
je veux juste signaler que la prison de
Lutterbach qui a ouvert il y a à peu
près il y a un peu moins d'un an
avait été annoncé en 2008 ou 2009 par
Michel Alliot-Marie donc il faut très
longtemps pour faire sortir une prison
de terre je ne pense pas que ce soit la
solution si on cherche des solutions
rapides disant enfin un peu plus rapide
que ça plus rapide que 10 ans j'ai été
un peu choquée de la réponse du ministre
de la Justice sur nos constats à la
prison de Gradignan surpeuplés à 245%
et qui
nous dit c'est pas grave parce que dans
deux ans une partie de nouvelles maisons
d'arrêt sortira de terre et dans quatre
ans une autre mais c'est maintenant
qu'il faudrait améliorer les choses et
j'en profite voilà et quant à la
réinsertion en détention et l'importance
des formations elle est énorme et c'est
pour ça que c'est pour ça que on
souhaite un ce mécanisme de régulation
carcérale afin que que les gens aient
taxé à la formation est accès le but
n'est pas la vengeance immédiate moi je
comprends très bien qu'on veuille se
venger si quelqu'un me fait du mal j'ai
une envie
c'est de lui mettre peut-être mon point
sur la figure ou pire oui c'est humain
ça mais heureusement il y a un truc qui
s'appelle la justice et qui fait que ça
n'est pas le Far West voilà
oui je ne connais pas Baba
malheureusement je vois qu'il y a deux
qui vous parlent mais je ne connais pas
personnellement
j'en parlerai à Baba si je le rencontre
et en tout cas
non d'accord en tout cas moi je vous
rejoins totalement sur la
prison marche sur deux jambes l'une qui
punit
et l'autre qui réincèrent et c'est
là-dessus que doivent porter nos efforts
parce que une peine de prison ne peut se
contenter d'être une vengeance ou une
punition elle doit aussi préparer les
gens à devenir un peu meilleur et ça
n'est pas être gauchiste que de dire ça
c'est peut-être très très réaliste
puisque ben oui non je répondais à
Madame du rassemblement national
qui m'a dit que je surfais sur l'esprit
gauchiste 68 armes disons que j'ai
évolué depuis l'esprit gaucher 68 tard
j'ai beaucoup vieilli depuis l'esprit
gaucher 68
hurry si vous merci c'est gentil enfin
mûri et j'en profite pour parler de mon
salaire j'ai jamais gagné autant
d'argent de ma vie c'est vrai ce n'est
pas 12000 euros c'est 10000 ce qui est
déjà énorme je le je le concède mais
je travaillais énormément donc je sais
pas quoi dire je n'allais pas non plus
aller demander une baisse de mon salaire
voilà
et
créer des places de prison je crois que
j'ai répondu à votre question c'est très
certes peut-être
moi je suis pas pour vous êtes pour bon
ce sont deux conceptions qui
s'affrontent mais de toute façon vous ne
trouverez pas la solution immédiate ça
n'est pas la solution demain vous ne
verrez pas surgir il faut 10 ans
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'élus qui prônent
il faut du temps beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'élus qui prônent la
construction de places de prison sont
contre la construction des places de
prison sur leur circonscription et
voilà et
quand je suis partie du Canard Enchaîné
j'avais haut comme ça de recours
d'élus et de résidents et de citoyens
contre la construction d'une prison
voilà vous parlez de prolifération des
portables en prison certes elle existe
elle existe de même que la prolifération
de la drogue en prison existe et de même
que cela sert parce que vous savez quand
on a fait cette réunion
au siège du contrôle général on était
assez fiers de réunir des gens qui ne se
parlent en général jamais moi j'ai
beaucoup de dialogues avec les
organisations syndicales de surveillant
mais il le reconnaisse qu'est-ce que
vous voulez oui le shit circule en
prison mais le shit sert aussi à calmer
les portables circulent en prison ça
sert aussi à calmer et il s'agit d'une
grande hypocrisie puisque plus tard on
parlera de l'internet c'est que certains
ont accès à l'internet beaucoup nous
appellent de leur portable et d'autres
n'ont pas accès il faut regarder la
réalité en face les choses ne sont pas
incantatoire
voilà moi aussi j'aimerais beaucoup que
les gens soient impars cellules et je
crois qu'on le voudrait tous et que et
que les prisons soient exemples de rate
cafard depuis NES de lit et qu'on puisse
y être soigné qu'on puisse y apprendre
des choses au lieu de ne rien y
apprendre et avouer que c'est quand même
du temps perdu du temps gâché et qui
nous coûte très cher
[Musique]
les mécanismes de régulation carcérale
pour répondre à Hugo bernalicis et bien
on peut les envisager de différentes
façons
il y a le modèle des ordonnances du
covid
rapide et bien fait il y a le numerus
clausus je crois que ça pose certaines
questions et que on trouvera plus de
gens qui sont contre que de gens qui
sont pour
et parmi les gens qui qu'on a réuni
l'autre jour il y a énormément de
questions qui sont posées des gens qui
sont plutôt très gauchistes ça va vous
surprendre qui n'était pas pour
pardon
non pas du tout ça me préoccupe je le
dis comme ça parce que je trouve ça
marrant
et des gens et des gens qui sont pas du
tout gauchistes et qui sont pour donc on
trouve de tout et les gens qu'on a réuni
c'est des gens qui ne se parlent jamais
d'habitude et qui se sont trouvés
d'accord sur des positions de principe
que sont oui ça ne peut pas durer donc
il faut qu'on trouve une solution pour
que les choses
s'améliorent
l'accès internet je laisserai André
ferraille vous en parler la polémique du
kart à Fresnes oui je l'ai trouvé
singulièrement triste parce que
tout le monde s'est bien pousser des
hurlements moi j'ai vu que pour une fois
les détenus et les surveillants
étaient ensemble
et que
il jouait à des jeux qui n'étaient pas
que la piscine enfin ce qu'on a appelé
pompeusement la piscine qui était un
gros bac
Esco et les deux tours de cartes il y a
deux détenus que fait des tours de
cartes
j'avoue que c'était surprenant comme
image mais moi je les ai trouvés plutôt
sympathiques et surtout les surveillants
et les détenus avaient l'air content
d'être ensemble et et n'oubliez pas
qu'après il regagnait pour les uns leurs
coursif pourri et pour les autres leurs
cellules pourries à trois dedans voilà
le téléphone
améliorer les choses quand il n'est pas
monsieur bernalicis rongé par les
cafards parce que j'ai et alors j'ai
appris à l'occasion de ma dernière
visite à Gradignan j'ignorais que les
cafards étaient des bestioles en plus
d'être désagréable très dangereuse pour
la santé je savais pas que ça filait des
maladies terribles et je savais pas non
plus que comme les souris elle grignote
ou les lapins ils grignotent les fils du
téléphone donc ils sont fort friands je
sais pas pourquoi et donc il y a
beaucoup de fils de téléphone
abîmés actuellement et je rappelle
également
que oui il y a une certaine hypocrisie à
savoir que les les téléphones
prolifèrent en détention et que
et qu'il n'y a pas d'accès Internet
alors
Monsieur
Eric
voilà posez merci vous n'êtes pas pour
la régulation
certes voilà j'en prends acte mais on
peut pas être tous d'accord n'est-ce pas
ils ne sont pas tous d'accord
heureusement que tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec tout le monde sinon ce
serait très ennuyeux
alors les centres de rétention
vous savez qui nous coûte énormément
cher je sais pas comment manier le
chiffre d'ailleurs que j'ai relevé de la
Cour des comptes sur le coup d'une
journée ensemble de rétention
tellement il m'a paru
hors du commun
moi je pense que oui plus de moyens
certainement que le bracelet
électronique c'est une solution très
intelligente
de même que l'assignation résidence est
une
est une solution très intelligente
plutôt que d'enfermer des gens qui
malheureusement enfin malheureusement
dans l'optique du gouvernement et dans
l'optique de la politique qui est
enclenché ne reparte pas
ça dépend pas
c'est oui vous le savez tous et toutes
ça dépend dans jeu diplomatique
quant à la
donc oui je trouve que c'est une
solution très bonne plutôt que
d'enfermer les gens là dedans
surtout que comme je vous le dis le
bracelet électronique coûtera infiniment
moins cher
quand je dis infiniment moins cher je
pèse mes mots c'est infiniment
d'infiniment moins cher
et que c'est quand même un souci
l'argent
quant à la rétention des mineurs bien
sûr
elle est indigne elle est quand on voit
ces images heureusement en France on
enferme beaucoup moins de mineurs que
dans d'autres pays que aux États-Unis
par exemple mais c'est vrai que c'est
effrayant de voir ses enfants fermés
on a été condamné pour ça et
l'assignation résidence est comme le
bracelet électronique une bonne solution
et beaucoup moins coûteuse parce que il
faut pas oublier que tout ça c'est de
l'argent public
nous avons c'est vrai
dresser
une un tableau alarmant de nos visites
de la surpopulation moi
quand vous me parlez de loi sur la
régulation carcérale je crois que j'ai
un peu répondu moi je suis pas nous ne
sommes pas législateurs mais ce qui a
été formidable dans la réunion dont je
vous parlais l'autre jour c'est que des
gens qui ne se parlent pas qui ne sont
en général pas d'accord sur rien était
d'accord au moins sur le fait qu'il faut
absolument trouver une solution pour que
la prison pour le prix qu'on paye
servent au moins à quelque chose parce
que mettre trois mois six mois un an des
gens à l'écart de la société d'accord ça
protège certainement la société mais si
ces gens ressortent dans le même état
qui sont entrés franchement ça n'a servi
à rien
et calculer le prix que ça nous a coûté
à 110 euros jour
pour le don le nombre de mois qu'on y
passe franchement c'est un système un
peu ancestral
un peu je dirais un peu
non pas bête mais un peu oui comme un
système qui se court après qui qui
n'arrive pas à trouver la sortie au fond
les mesures sur le travail qui ont été
annoncées
c'est extrêmement c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué le travail parce
que peut-être vous le savez il y a
énormément d'abord d'entreprises de luxe
moi j'étais très étonnée de visiter des
ateliers ou on emballe des produits
extrêmement luxueux bon il y a eu un
jour concessionnaire m'a dit alors moi
mon client là il est entré dans
l'atelier pour faire une petite visite
il a vu des crottes de rat à côté de ses
pots de crème il a dit
c'est pas possible je m'en vais moi
chaque fois que comme journaliste j'ai
visité des ateliers en mai surtout
taisez-vous ne dites absolument pas ne
citer pas le nom des des sociétés qui
qui donne du travail elles ne veulent
pas j'ai jamais su c'était à cause de
l'image ça renvoyait que des détenus en
balles des pots de crème
emballe des rouges à lèvres ou si c'est
parce qu'il y avait les crottes de rat
ou si c'est à cause du salaire que
touche les détenus je sais pas qu'est-ce
qui en tout cas ils ne veulent surtout
pas que mais ce que je sais c'est que
plus il y a de contraintes plus ces
entreprises menacent de s'en aller
notamment si on menace menace d'une
hausse de salaire ils disent ben s'en va
ce que je comprends pas c'est comment on
fait l'Allemagne
pour qui est 70% des détenus qui
travaillent dans les prisons allemandes
et seul 30% qui ne travaillent pas parce
qu'ils ne veulent ou ne peuvent pas et
que nous le ratio est inverse c'est 30%
des détenus qui travaillent
on augmente on était à 25
on va pas on va pas cracher sur même sur
les petits progrès
l'autre mère et Mayotte c'est je sais
que la situation était épouvantable et
nous allons nous y rendre parce qu'il y
a longtemps qu'on n'est pas allé à
Mayotte
effectivement
franchement
c'est une situation
j'ai mal au cœur de vous dire que on va
s'y rendre on va faire le même constat
que vous et je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer après mais je sachez que on est à
vos côtés et préoccupé au combien de
de la situation à Mayotte à la Réunion
je sais pas mais à mon avis ça dépasse
les conditions d'hébergement les
conditions ça dépasse c'est des enjeux
qui tiennent à la pauvreté du Sri Lanka
au chaos politique
à l'accueil des réfugiés politiques
quant à la mort horrible de Yvan Colonna
si vous voulez on en arrive à se dire
que
il se connaissait moi vous savez on nous
a demandé de nous pencher de nous saisir
de cette enquête mais je pense qu'il y a
une enquête interne une enquête
judiciaire une enquête de l'inspection
générale de la justice je crois que nous
à quoi on servirait là-dedans que à ce
marché sur les pieds les uns des autres
le statut de dps on avait conçu comme
une victoire que les dps puissent enfin
une victoire que les dps puissent
accéder à un travail puis circuler je
vais pas reculer là-dessus c'est un
drame
épouvantable j'ai pas d'autres mots pour
qualifier ça est-ce que ce type ne
devait pas se trouver là
j'attends ce que nous dira l'enquête
apparemment il y a eu quelques
défaillances
notamment dans la surveillance vidéo
mais c'est en fait l'habitude
de se dire c'est de là finalement il
s'entendait pas mal
il va en colonnaille et son assassin où
son meurtrier on verra ou un meurtre
il s'entendait pas mal alors je me dis
peut-être le surveillant c'est dit à
quoi bon les surveiller
l'enquête nous le dira et de toute façon
vu le choc est long de choc ça que ça
produit je pense que l'enquête on la
lira tous avec attention et moi je
on a déjà l'enquête générale de
l'inspection générale mais l'enquête
judiciaire ira plus loin j'imagine
et André je vais te laisser répondre sur
l'Internet en prison
merci donc sur l'Internet en prison
c'est un sujet sur lequel le contrôle le
CGLPL a rendu il y a 2 ans ou 3
peut-être mais pas plus un avis
extrêmement précis pour ne pas dire un
peu technique
c'était vie de mémoire rappelle les
enjeux de l'accès Internet en prison
notamment les enjeux en termes
d'insertion et en termes de liens
familiaux et prend en compte la
dimension de sécurité qui s'attache à la
mise en place de l'Internet en prison
les préconisations qui sont faites sont
des préconisations qui sont
techniquement bordés qui préconise la
mise en place d'un système d'accès à
Internet avec on va dire trois
dimensions première dimension l'accès au
site en simple lecture c'est à dire
aussi non interactif sans aucune
possibilité de réponse sans aucune
possibilité
d'accès pour lequel nous pren un système
de liste noire c'est-à-dire que tout ce
qui n'est pas interdit doit être
autorisé en d'autres termes un site de
simples informations le site d'un
journal sans possibilité de répondre de
poster des commentaires les gifrance le
site de l'Assemblée nationale
tout ça doit être autorisé sauf si il y
a une raison particulière d'interdire
ainsi parce qu'il porterait des
informations susceptibles de d'avoir une
influence fâcheuse sur la sécurité en
détention le deuxième sujet important
c'est tout ce qui concerne la
réinsertion la réinsertion c'est-à-dire
l'accès à l'enseignement l'accès aux
prestations sociales
l'accès aux droits en général au
logement et ça nous prenons un système
au contraire de liste blanche
c'est-à-dire un système dans lequel un
certain nombre de sites préalablement
techniquement contrôlés serait
expressément autorisé ainsi on pourrait
avoir la liste de autorisé tel le site
de le site du CNED celui de Pôle Emploi
celui d'un service de prestation sociale
et là à partir du moment où ce sont des
sites sur lesquels il faudrait ouvrir
une possibilité d'interaction nous avons
proposé un système de liste blanche
c'est-à-dire d'expression
de d'autorisation express en troisième
lieu il y a la question des liens
familiaux sur lequel nous avons
préconisé la mise en place de systèmes
de messagerie fermée c'est-à-dire pas la
possibilité d'envoyer des mails
librement à tout le monde mais de mettre
en place sur un système de messagerie
fermée à l'intérieur de notre système de
site internet nous utilisons tous des
messageries fermées même si elles sont
très larges là on pourrait en faire de
plus étroites un système de messagerie
fermée avec des destinataires et des
destinataires autorisés qui soit un
système aussi contrôlé que le sont les
échanges téléphoniques officiels mais
cet ensemble nous paraît à la fois
avons besoin et tenir compte des
contraintes de sécurité donc c'est un
système sur lequel nous avons
nous avons un
avis extrêmement technique extrêmement
précis dont je viens de vous rappeler
donc la teneur alors je réponds aux
questions qui ont été posées sur
la psychiatrie oui sur la question de la
psychiatrie et notamment il y avait
pardon la question des départs de
médecins est-ce que nous constatons les
départs de médecins oui nous constatons
les départs de médecins
tout simplement parce que le déficit de
la de la démographie médicale que l'on
observe dans les hôpitaux sur se trouve
aussi dans la médecine libérale donc un
médecin qui un psychiatre qui quitte
l'hôpital n'a aucune difficulté à se
faire une clientèle libérale dans la
localité
de son choix puisqu'il n'y a jamais que
je sache d'excès d'offres de soins en
médecine et en psychiatrie libérale nous
avons rencontré hier de psychiatre dont
l'une était de psychiatre hospitalier
dont l'une appartenait un hôpital dans
lequel dans la circonscription duquel il
existe il existe aucune autre offre de
soins que son propre service
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de clinique
psychiatrique et il n'y a pas de
psychiatrie mutualiste il n'y a pas de
psychiatrie libérale il s'agit de
l'hôpital de Mantes-la-Jolie donc sur
l'ensemble de son secteur il n'y a pas
d'offre donc le jour où cette personne
souhaitera pour une raison qui lui
appartient qui était l'hôpital elle aura
sa zone de clientèle immédiate sur place
donc le sortie de l'hôpital et
extrêmement facile alors quand aux
raisons pour lesquelles il part des
raisons que vous avez cité monsieur le
député sont tout invoqués chacun à
chacune à son tour les uns sont en
désaccord avec des questions des
exigences procédurales les autres sont
fatigués de travailler dans un ensemble
dans un contexte où les moyens font
défaut d'autres enfin ça vous ne l'avez
pas cité mais nous l'avions recueilli
des témoignages là-dessus dans notre
rapport annuel de 2019
partent par
hostilité au contexte de travail de la
psychiatrie dans lequel certains
psychiatres considère qu'il est nombreux
considèrent qu'il y a un poids excessif
des exigences médicales
et notamment le témoignage que nous
avions recueilli en 2019 et publié dans
notre rapport annuel que qui n'a pas
tellement perdu de son actualité que je
vous invite des relire était celui d'une
jeune femme psychiatre à Toulouse et qui
s'inquiétait de recours à la psychiatrie
pour traiter la question de la
radicalisation qui à l'époque commençait
à être une idée qui s'estompait qui
disparaissait mais qu'elle craignait de
voir remplacer toujours à l'époque par
l'idée du recours à la psychiatrie pour
traiter les violences conjugales ou les
problèmes de délinquance sexuelle et
donc
la crainte qu'on les psychiatres de voir
leur profession qui est une profession
de soins que tu es une profession de
prise en charge médicale des voyelles
vers de la prise en charge médico légale
est aussi pour certains une cause de
départ vers le libéral
voilà
sinon je sur le centre de rétention
administrative de la Réunion
la question posée était précise je n'ai
pas la réponse en tête en revanche je me
propose de vous faire parvenir le les
contacts nous avons fait à notre
dernière visite à La Réunion qui était
il y a quelques années
il y a trois ans je crois
j'ai 9 questions peut-être vous vous
donnez un élément de débat qu'on a eu
hier lors de l'examen de la mission
justice c'est le plan de 15000 en termes
de places de prison
alors on a je sais pas si vous allez
comprendre en tout cas quelques éléments
d'abord sur les ouvertures de place sur
le dernier quinquennat il y a eu 3300
ouvertures pour 1300 fermetures ce qui
fait un solde à 2000 places qui sont les
places nouvellement créées 500 sont
attendus dans les prochains mois et je
crois que garde des Sceaux a d'hier que
c'est dans les six prochains mois
d'ouverture de 500 nouvelle places qui
feraient 2500 places réellement ouvertes
7000 sont engagés c'est-à-dire au stade
donc en comptant naturellement les les
2000 en soldes que je viens que je viens
de dénoncer 7000 sont déjà engagés ça
veut dire que soit elles ont été livrées
soit elles sont en cours de construction
soit au moins les études ou les permis
ont été déposées il reste les 8000 qui
sont pour le coup aujourd'hui pendant et
pour lequel garde des sceaux nous a fait
part de toutes une série de difficultés
notamment
des élus locaux qui ont des gros points
de gros point noir aujourd'hui ou quand
il faut implanter une prison tout le
monde est d'accord sauf si ça se trouve
sur le territoire de sa commune ou de
ses élus sur le deux observations
également par rapport à notre visite à
Fresnes sur le cannabis en prison alors
c'est vrai que très régulièrement
l'odeur de cannabis est caractéristique
de la prison en revanche ce qu'on a pu
constater à Fresnes et c'était notable
parce que pour le coup il y avait pas
cette odeur et ce que nous disait le
directeur non mais c'est vrai et le
directeur nous faisait remarquer qu'il y
avait une en tout cas le directeur et
les directions de la surveillance nous
est observé que une une attention
particulière avait été faite sur les
fouilles sur les saisies et sur tout ce
qui était le finalement la lutte
antidrogue dans la prison de sorte qu'il
y avait une très forte réduction depuis
le mois de juin dernier à la prison de
Fresnes avec une entrée beaucoup moins
importante bon l'actualité démontre que
il y a des nouveaux procédés qui ont été
utilisés pour introduire de la drogue en
prison mais jusqu'à présent en tout cas
pour l'avoir constaté c'était surprenant
parce que à Fresnes
précisément il n'y avait pas cette de
cette odeur qui je le redis et
normalement caractéristiques de la
prison dernière chose sur le site sur le
sur les détenus et le travail en prison
effectivement on est et vous l'avez
remarqué on est on est très loin des
standards allemands sur ces questions le
nouveau contrat de travail était en
vigueur lorsqu'on est allé en prison
notamment à Fresnes avec deux
caractéristiques c'est à dire
l'augmentation du salaire qui est
désormais à 45% du SMIC les droits
sociaux nouveaux les cotisations
acquises pour l'assurance vieillesse
l'assurance chômage etc
en revanche une chose très surprenante
et quand on discutait avec les détenus
ça nous a marqué Clara chassagnol
Benjamin Ada de Gilles Legendre au moins
c'est que les détenus ne connaissent pas
ses droits et lorsque on en a discuté
avec eux on leur note c'est comme si on
avait une notification de ses droits
alors même que pour le coup c'est
quelque chose qui est assez intéressant
parce que dès lors qu'ils sont ouverts
ils ouvriraient une fois la réinsertion
en milieu ouvert et bien forcément des
choses ou des un accès des services
publics qui seraient intéressante pour
eux en tout cas c'était c'était assez
instructif de ce point de vue là je
redonne la parole aux différents
commissaires en commençant par Monsieur
Rémy Rebeyrotte
madame la contrôleur vous m'avez choqué
notamment sur votre approche des centres
éducatifs fermés
vous avez parlé d'antichambre de la
prison or je pense que c'est exactement
l'inverse
c'est-à-dire que l'objectif c'est
d'éviter qu'un certain nombre de mineurs
passe par la case prison pour les
mineurs au profit d'une tentative
tentative parce que ça c'est loin d'être
à qui d'avance d'une tentative d'une
approchée éducative par l'apprentissage
par tout un réseau qui se met en place
en leur faveur à condition vous avez dit
que ça fonctionne oui ça on peut dire
cela de tout évidemment les institutions
et à condition que l'orientation des
magistrats soit j'allais dire opportunes
et que les choses se passent évidemment
dans les meilleures conditions mais je
me rappelle d'une étude faite par nos
collègues sénateurs qui disaient qu'en
gros on était à 50% de sorties
positive alors positive
ça veut pas dire que tout était réglé je
rappelle que ces jeunes ont commis des
actes extrêmement graves extrêmement
lourds mais du moins de sorties qui
évitait une forme de récidive
rapide et qui permettait une orientation
vers une reprise de la vie en société
alors je voudrais savoir exactement ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous êtes
plutôt favorable à la prison pour mineur
ou est-ce que vous êtes plutôt favorable
à développer ces centres éducatifs et
dans quelles conditions
bref voilà je voudrais connaître votre
point de vue là dessus et savoir quelles
sont vos préconisations
merci Monsieur Stéphane Rambaud
contrôleur général vous avez rendu en
juillet dernier un rapport intitulé
l'intimité au risque de la privation de
liberté si on résume votre pensée vous
alerter l'administration pénitentiaire
et la société sur le manque de respect
de la vie privée engendré par les
besoins de sécurité et la surpopulation
carcérale vous écrivez l'intimité peut
être mise à mal dans de nombreux aspects
de la privation de liberté de manière
souvent disproportionnée
conditions d'hébergement promiscuité
mesure de contrainte fouille au corps
correspondance confidentialité des soins
visite des proches ou encore sexualité
mais madame
la prison n'a jamais été conçue pour
être un lieu de vie législature
dans de bonnes conditions d'hygiène et
des sécurités des détenus les vertus de
la prison sont nombreuses et je le
répète parce que je suis autant
humaniste que vous dans de bonnes
conditions d'hygiène et des sécurités
des détenus les vertus de la prison sont
nombreuses et le permet de réparer le
préjudice subi par les victimes oui les
victimes
en mettant à l'écart les individus
dangereux la prison concourent aussi à
protéger la société des désordres les
plus graves enfin elle contribue à
dissuader les condamnés à récidiver car
c'est une évidence et vous le savez
l'impunité c'est elle qui crée la
récidive à ce propos je souhaite ici
rendre hommage aux surveillant pour leur
travail
l'intimité des prisonniers c'est une
chose la sécurité des personnels
pénitentiaires s'en est une autre or
partout en France les surveillants
subissent la violence de détenus qui
cherche à imposer leur propre loi en
prison ces dernières années les
agressions contre les surveillants ont
été nombreuses et cela n'est pas
tolérable alors comment mieux assurer la
protection des surveillants
pénitentiaires et leur permettre de
faire leur travail de de bonnes
conditions que vous le vouliez ou non
merci cette question
Monsieur Antoine léoman merci monsieur
le Président Madame Simonneau je veux
déjà vous remercier pour le point que
vous avez fait et qui montre bien la
dureté de la prison et de vos mots j'ai
retenu cette phrase on paye 110 euros
par jour pour que les gens sortent de la
pierre qui n'y sont entrés vous avez
montré à quel point la prison est dure
et en vous entendant certains et
d'ailleurs ils l'ont fait notamment nos
collègues du rassemblement national nous
disent la prison c'est pas fait pour
s'amuser c'est pas un lieu de vieilles
signature on nous a même dit et
effectivement c'est on est loin de
prison qui serait des lieux de
vieillesiatures vous avez parlé la
réalité de la maladie notamment qui peut
se développer des conditions d'hygiène
qui sont qui sont très mauvaises en
réalité si on en revient au fond la
prison elle a deux missions la première
c'est purger une peine de privation de
liberté dans la loi il est mis vous êtes
vous êtes puni à un an
grande prison il est pas mis vous êtes
puni d'un an de prison avec des cafards
avec des rats sans douche etc c'est une
privation de liberté point le deuxième
point c'est que une fois la peine purgé
la personne puisse se réinsérer dans la
société et donc la prison à l'objectif
normalement d'éviter la récidive du coup
j'ai une question qui est assez simple
pensez-vous que la prison actuellement
soit la bonne méthode pour empêcher la
récidive et puis pour aller un peu plus
loin je dirais qu'il existe des moyens
alternatifs dont on a parlé hier le
placement à l'extérieur notamment qui
permet un taux de récidive bien plus
faible j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
pensez de ce type de de d'aménagement de
peine et puis enfin juste comme il me
reste 20 secondes je voudrais savoir ce
que vous pensez du fait parce que mon
collègue Bernat ici se me l'a demandé
que le ministre de la Justice introduise
demain dans le projet de loi de finances
par amendement un prorogation du
moratoire sur l'enseignement individuel
qui normalement s'arrêter au 31 décembre
2022 Monsieur Emmanuel Mondon
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleur général je voudrais
relever tout d'abord votre appréciation
comme ça vient d'être dit à l'égarder
centre éducatif fermé un modèle selon
vous qui n'est pas stabilisé rejoignant
ainsi d'autres conclusions sur une
formule qui qui fait débat
mais je souhaiterais attirer votre
attention sur la situation particulière
du centre pénitentiaire de la Talaudière
dans la métropole de Saint-Étienne vous
y êtes déplacé le 5 septembre dernier je
crois je me suis rendu à mon tour deux
semaines plus tard j'aimerais partager
bien sûr quelques impressions sur cette
prison mais je me bandrais ici à vous
poser trois questions la première
pouvez-vous nous indiquer ce qui vous a
amené à vous intéresser à son
fonctionnement
la seconde c'est simplement pour
assister sur le fait qu'il y a une
réhabilitation à hauteur de 15 millions
d'euros qui ont été débloqués en vue
d'une réhabilitation qui n'est que
partielle en lui et place d'une
démolition reconstruction qui avait été
envisagé et que nous aurions souhaité
cette prison datant de 68 c'est à dire
une époque où on ne construisait pas de
locaux destinée à durer
ainsi depuis 2019 donc trois phases de
travaux ont été engagés avec une
sécurisation périmétrique d'un mur
d'enceinte pour lutter contre les
intrusions et réduire les nuisances dans
son victime les riverains avec
l'installation de douche dans les
cellules sur les bâtiments B et A
enfin la perspective de la démolition
reconstruction du bâtiment administratif
toujours en attente d'arbitrage alors
que pensez-vous de cette réhabilitation
qui je le rappelle devait répondre à la
triple objective garantit la sécurité
des riverains améliorer les conditions
de travail des personnels pénitentiaires
et améliorer les conditions
d'incarcération car ceci est tout lié et
on doit avoir une approche globale alors
troisième question madame la contrôleur
général dans le cadre de votre mission
vous pouvez vous préciser quels sont vos
constats et vos premières
recommandations s'il vous plaît pour cet
établissement merci merci Monsieur
Timothée
merci Madame le contrôleur général
merci même le contrôleur général ma
question concerne l'Institut national
des hautes études de la sécurité et de
la justice organisme interministériel
supprimer en 2019 par Emmanuel Macron il
visait à faire de la sécurité nationale
un sujet d'étude transversale en
regroupant de nombreux acteurs de la
société civile et privés travaillant sur
les différentes politiques publiques en
matière de justice et de sécurité le
caractère interministériel de cette
institut et son positionnement formé
l'enceinte adaptée de production du
savoir à l'attention des décideurs
publics dans le cadre de l'élaboration
des politiques de sécurité il permettait
de dépasser les clivages les rivalités
de chapelle et les logiques de corps au
sein d'une structure nommée observatoire
national de la délinquance et des
réponses pénales qui a également été
supprimée il était aussi chargé
d'étudier les évolutions statistiques de
l'ensemble du processus pénal
l'exécution des peines et des sanctions
pénales ainsi que la récidive
la suppression de cette organisme a
signifié la fin des études indépendantes
en matière de criminalité et de
délinquance mais aussi en matière
d'application des peines et de réponses
pénale désormais passer sous la férule
du ministère de l'intérieur sous la
forme de l'Institut des hautes études du
ministère de l'Intérieur trouvez-vous
normal que le ministère de l'intérieur
soit le seul juge et analyste de sa
propre action comment garantir des
études indépendantes et n'est-il pas
nécessaire de rétablir l'Institut
national des hautes études de la
sécurité de la justice et l'Observatoire
national de la délinquance et des
réponses pénales et puisqu'il me reste
quelques secondes de parole je voudrais
aussi vous poser une question sur les
coûts des journées de rétention parce
que depuis tout à l'heure vous nous avez
parlé plusieurs fois du coup des
journées d'attention en disant qu'il
était absolument faramineux mais vous ne
nous avez pas donné le chiffre donc
j'aimerais que vous nous le donniez
madame Daniel obono en visio
bonjour monsieur le Président collègue
et Madame la contrôleur merci beaucoup
pour votre introduction et de tout le
travail que font
vos équipes je sais que ce n'est pas un
sujet sur lesquels vous appuyez vous
étiez vous êtes plus plutôt
sur sur la question du suivi de
recommandations mais je voulais rappeler
quand même que vous faites ce travail
éminemment important avec des moyens
pour le moins modeste et comme nous
sommes en période de discussion
budgétaire je crois que c'est quelque
chose que nous devrions avoir en tête et
la nécessité pour assurer ce travail de
contrôle que vous ayez l'ensemble des
moyens
nécessaires pour pour le faire dans de
bonnes conditions je voulais revenir sur
un propos des propos que vous avez eu
concernant les centres éducatifs fermés
et surtout sur le fait que vous disiez
que il y avait à la fois des expériences
très très bien très très intéressantes
mais d'autres qui étaient beaucoup plus
problématiques et vous en concluez que
le modèle n'était pas arrêté mais
j'aimerais avoir des éléments peut-être
plus précis parce que
si c'est du 50/50 on peut se dire ça
validerait le fait de pouvoir continuer
et d'ailleurs c'est la c'est le choix
politique qui est qui a été pris sur sur
ce sujet puisque c'est un des modèles
qui est mis en avant et
les les
l'ouverture de structure continue il est
prévu
d'ailleurs que c'est ces dispositifs
continuent à être à être à être mis en
place or c'est une des questions sur
lesquelles pour notre part nous sommes
assez en accord avec celles et ceux qui
demandent la fermeture de ces centres
éducatifs fermées étant donné
dans lesquels s'exerce
l'encadrement des jeunes la surveillance
et
l'accompagnement qui est supposé à notre
accompagnement avant tout éducatif je
rappelle que les centres éducatifs
fermés
doivent avoir une dizaine de mineurs et
on fait l'objet de beaucoup de critiques
nous avons nous-mêmes été interpellés
sur ce sujet par des membres de ces
centres étant donné les conditions et
donc oui j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
proportion selon vous est-ce qu'on est
du 50/50 est-ce qu'on est du 90 sur sur
le sujet de la continuité de ces centres
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté ma question portera
aussi également sur sur les CEF à
l'instar de mon collègue rebey Roth j'ai
été aussi également interpellé par la
position qui est la vôtre s'agissant des
centres éducatifs fermés pour rappel à
cette commission nous avons aujourd'hui
51f 20 sont en construction ils ont été
décidés
Nicole Belloubet qui avait engagé la
construction de ces 20 nouveaux CF et
cette construction elle est pas le fruit
ni la décision de la seule garde des
sceaux je crois que c'était un travail
mûrement réfléchi en amont de
d'interrogations des magistrats
notamment et j'invite mes collègues qui
critiquent le fonctionnement des SEFs à
venir assister aux auditions qui sont
les nôtres dans le cadre de l'évaluation
du code de justice pénale des mineurs et
ils verront que l'ensemble des
magistrats sont unanimes pour dire
qu'ils ont besoin de CF parce que c'est
des lieux évidemment
d'encadrement de mineurs qui sont assez
exceptionnels je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler aussi également ici un CF c'est
26 et TP pour 12 mineurs c'est à dire
qu'on a un encadrement de plus de deux
éducateurs pour un seul mineur à
travailler éducatif qui se fait sur six
mois et qui est bien au-delà de ce que
propose d'autres structures je pense au
centre éducatif renforcé notamment où on
a à peu près et en moyenne un éducateur
pour trois mineurs et donc un travail
très qualitatif qui se fait avec les
mineurs je crois que ce que vous évoquez
dans le cadre de vos
[Musique]
des éléments que vous avez constaté dans
un certain nombre de self il découle
notamment je pense de deux situations la
première situation c'est que de mon
point de vue des mineurs entre trop
tardivement dans le cadre de santé
éducatifs fermées on arrive avec des
mineurs qui sont complètement inadaptés
à ce type de structure soit parce qu'ils
ont des problèmes psychologiques soit
parce qu'ils ont des problèmes
psychiatriques ça c'est la première
élément et le deuxième élément on a
aussi également des mineurs qui ont fait
l'objet de nombreuses condamnations et
pour lesquelles l'autorité judiciaire
telle qu'elle intervient et bien n'est
pas conforme au placement dans ce type
de structure mais encore une fois je
crois que ces systèmes ont fait
l'épreuve c'est encore une fois je le
rappelle deux éducateurs pour
je suis désolé monsieur t'allais je suis
obligé de vous couper madame
Marie-France Leroux
oui merci Président Madame
moi c'est un constat une interrogation
qui s'impose à moi c'est vrai qu'il y a
5 ans j'ai fait la visite avec beaucoup
de députés présents ici la première
visite à Fresnes malheureusement j'ai
pas pu faire la deuxième pour X raisons
mais ce qui m'interpelle c'est que 5 ans
ont passé des constats ont été faits
quand on a fait la première visite et on
a l'impression quand on vous entend
madame le contrôleur que en fait pas
grand chose à bouger donc je voulais
savoir voilà on fait des visites et
derrière si rien rien ne bouge c'est un
petit peu compliqué quoi ça sert donc
faire des constats est-ce qu'on va en
refaire un dans cinq ans et ça sera la
même chose voilà c'est juste la question
merci
bonjour à toutes et à tous je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir pu vous rendre
jusqu'à nous afin qu'on puisse aborder
ce sujet de réalité au sein des lieux de
privation de liberté dans notre pays je
pense qu'évidemment ça ne peut que nous
préoccuper
je crois que le fond de la faire et le
fait que nous ne nous contentions pas
que la France ne se contente pas de
considérer que la sanction est de fait
l'apprivation de liberté et que pour
autant il n'est pas utile d'en ajouter
d'en ajouter en particulier en absence
en particulier en termes d'absence de
respect de la dignité qui est due à
chaque être humain et qui fait
d'ailleurs que le pays est condamné
régulièrement
bien évidemment on a tous conscience que
cette affaire est aussi liée à un regard
social un regard de la société voir dans
un certain nombre de cas une démagogie
énorme moi mon sujet à la suite d'un
certain nombre de questions qui ont été
posées portent sur le constat
regrettable et malheureux que l'on peut
faire du fait qu'il y a 6 fois plus de
suicide en prison qu'en milieu
ordinaire je ne sais comment comment
dire les choses
qu'il y en a eu 122 en 2021 et qu'au
fond ça représente un décès tous les
deux ou trois jours donc je souhaitais
vous vous entendre sur sur cette sur
cette réalité
qui est sans doute liée à ce que je
disais précédemment c'est à dire le fait
qu'on n'est pas cette volonté politique
de se limiter au fait de priver de de
liberté ce qui est encore une fois est
déjà absolument énorme comme sanction
merci
[Musique]
j'ai nommé rapporteur au Parlement donc
je vous prie de m'excuser vous êtes une
autre autorité indépendante madame la
contre la générale
je vais répondre d'abord sur les centres
éducatifs fermés c'est une question qui
me préoccupe énormément qui nous
préoccupé énormément et j'ai je suis
contente qu'elle vous préoccupe aussi
parce que vous avez dit que vous aviez
été choqué par mes propos
je crois que c'est monsieur ribeirotte
qui a dit ça
oui je crois mais
il faut pas vous méprendre comme je vous
ai dit on a visité des centres éducatifs
fermés qui justement sont absolument
formidables mais il faut bien avoir
conscience que le problème des centres
éducatif fermé et de plusieurs ordres
d'abord
on tombe sur des centres ou vous avez
beau me dire vous pouvez me dire il y a
26 TP pour 12 mineurs qui sont ces ETP
c'est le problème est là parce que il y
a des endroits où on a su construire et
et garder des équipes pérennes formées
solides qui savent répondre
à des gamins qui sont on le sait tous
pas facile du tout et même très
difficile même si on a des problèmes
psychiatriques qui dépassent le centre
éducatif fermé mais
il y en a d'autres où les équipes
ne font que tourner un turnover horrible
il y a enfin horrible
sans cesse et plus personne ne veut
faire ce boulot il n'est pas attractif
moi j'ai noté dans celui dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui qui servait les
repas à la maison de retraite
fabriquaient des meubles pour la mairie
etc et où tout se passait bien j'ai noté
que l'équipe depuis 10 ans est
absolument pérenne et inchangés les gens
sont mieux formés mieux et mieux payés
il y a peut-être de ça aussi
qu'ailleurs en tout cas la direction a
fait en sorte de préserver son équipe et
il est vrai que ce ce sel pour moi c'est
c'était
le premier que j'ai visité et j'étais
mais ravi ravi malheureusement comme je
vous le disais on en a vu d'autres où
c'était pas ça du tout donc
il faut il faut bien regarder ça en face
et se dire que oui un self c'est
certainement mieux que la prison mais je
pense que c'est pas mieux si c'est
n'importe quoi voyez on a vu par exemple
un centre éducatif fermé ou deux
éducateurs pendant le covid avait été
recruté parce que leur boîte de nuit
avait fermé ils sont dit tiens on va
faire du social ils ont été embauchés
dans le centre éducatif fermé
exact voilà donc il faut il faut une
équipe pérenne bien dirigée voilà il
faut que ce soit bien ensuite l'autre
problème c'est que les enfants et
adolescents qui arrivent dans les
centres éducatifs fermés ils ont un
passé vous savez que de façon assez
bizarre il n'existe pas d'études
longitudinale des jeunes
qui sont placés à l'ASE parce qu'il y a
une majorité de gamins accueilli dans
les cèves qui viennent de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance que on ne s'épanou ils
viennent les éducateurs nous l'ont dit
moi je ne sais pas d'où il vient je ne
connais pas son passé et pire encore je
ne connais pas je ne connaîtrai pas son
avenir une fois qu'il sera parti parce
qu'il y a pas d'études après donc
comment savoir ce qui marche et ce qui
ne marche pas ça c'est un reproche qu'on
peut faire à la France un peu de c'est
ce manque de sérieux dans le dans le
suivi dans le dans le
dans l'évaluation des politiques
publiques
c'est dommage voilà autrement moi
comme je vous dis j'avais pas pour les
self une particulière appétence et quand
mais quand j'en ai visité j'ai changé
d'avis et je me suis dit mais oui quand
c'est un bon sève et bien ça peut être
formidable mais quand c'est mauvais ça
peut être épouvantable
comment
non je disais ça vaut pour beaucoup
et c'est moins fréquent là c'est
vraiment on passe du pire au meilleur et
quand c'est le pire je vous assure c'est
voilà donc alors sur les self il y avait
d'autres questions
[Musique]
oui je crois que j'ai répondu c'est
certain peut-être les mineurs y arrivent
trop tardivement ça
et avant d'arriver dans ce SF il vivait
dans sa voix dans une voiture avec ses
parents donc je pense que oui il est
arrivé un peu tardivement dans le
système
social c'est sûr
j'arrivais pas à comprendre comment
personne s'était soucier
ni ses profs personne du sort de cet
enfant oui c'était parce qu'il était un
peu disons
pas dire enfin il était un peu différent
disons et et de voir arriver à l'école
au lycée au collège je ne sais pas un
gosse de 17 ans qui n'a plus de dents et
qui se sont tous je pense et qui a un
doudou en permanence et qui dort avec
une tétine je pense que
oui le problème aurait pu être détecté
avant et c'est tout le problème des
enfants de l'ASE yeux parce qu'on parle
beaucoup du contrôle des EHPAD mais on
ne parle pas assez du contrôle
totalement défaillant des familles
d'accueil des foyers de l'enfance ou je
vois que le sujet parce que moi c'est
pas notre compétence nous on les
récupère dans les centres éducatifs
fermés mais enfin il y a un énorme
problème de l'enfance en danger en
France et qui n'est pas du tout
pris parce que à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance comme ailleurs il y a une
désaffection pour ce métier c'est très
regrettable faudra peut-être les rendre
plus attractifs enfin il y a un problème
aussi de contrôle des endroits où on
envoie ses enfants où ils sont parfois
extraordinairement maltraités et
et c'est notre avenir et c'est nos
enfants à tous et c'est quand même
et c'est nos concitoyens bientôt donc il
va falloir qu'on
se penche sur le problème mais je vois
avec plaisir que le sujet commence à
émerger
excusez-moi sur la
sur la proportion en fait
non vous m'avez dit la pas j'essaie
parce que c'est une question qui m'a été
posée à la proportion de sève qui marche
et qui marche pas
j'ai pas tellement d'idées puisque c'est
fluctuant voyez on a visité un sève qui
marchait extraordinairement bien
qui a marché comme ça trois mois jusqu'à
ce qu'on se rende compte qu'il y avait
un énorme problème avec la directrice
c'est je sais pas quoi vous dire je
est-ce que tu peux dire toi André je ne
peux pas répondre à la question de la
proportion que je peux dire c'est que
c'est des structures extrêmement
volatiles dans lesquels je dirais que
quand on va dans un cèdre comme ça
intuitivement on a une chance sur deux
pour que ce soit bon et une chance sur
deux pour que ce soit très mauvais
et c'est pas prévisible parce que un
chef peut passer du tout autour en
fonction d'un changement d'équipe en
fonction d'un changement de pro des
pédagogue projet pédagogique
CEF ne pourra pas me semble-t-il il y a
deux ou trois ans qu'on y est pas allé
maintenant donc ça a peut-être changé
mais ne peut pas trouver une équipe
professionnelle sur place et non non pas
sur le rapport intimité mise à mal dans
les lieux de privation de liberté on ne
parlait pas que des prisons d'ailleurs
on parlait de tous les lieux qu'on
visite oui l'intimité est mise à mal
elle est mise à mal en prison par la
surpopulation et bien sûr je
n'avons jamais dit que la prison était
censée être une vie légitaire et
d'ailleurs on en est très loin et j'ai
été fort étonné d'ailleurs
et fort inquiète quand j'ai entendu des
élus après l'histoire du karting à
Fresnes dire ah ben voilà c'est la
prison 4 étoiles c'est l'hôtel 4 étoiles
c'est
c'est la la vie légère te le centre le
Club Med
mais comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire je prie pour que ces élus n'ouvrent
jamais ni hôtel ni Club Med parce que
c'est une vision assez apocalypsectique
de l'hôtel 4 étoiles mais bon
oui l'intimité mise à mal que l'intimité
que l'intimité soit mise à mal dans les
lieux de privation de liberté c'est un
fait elle l'aide en prison par la
surpopulation je vois pas qui d'entre
nous supporterait d'être à trois dans
ces conditions dans une cellule vous
allez me dire on n'est pas tous censés
avoir comme idée des lits qui nous amène
là j'en suis d'accord mais j'en suis
d'accord mais pour pour réparer la
société
je ne pense pas que ce soit bon
d'antasser les gens de cette façon la
privation de liberté
ça doit être la privation de liberté
c'est déjà la punie la punition c'est ça
et ensuite l'autre jambe comme quelqu'un
l'a dit très justement c'est la
réinsertion et la réinsertion ça passe
par l'apprentissage de quelque chose
d'autre par exemple quand on pense qu'il
y a 20% d'illettrés en prison c'est un
chiffre préoccupant sur notre école
la sécurité des surveillants mais nous
nous sommes parfaitement d'accord
d'ailleurs vous lirez dans nos rapports
à quel point nous nous entretenons
systématiquement avec tous les
surveillants que l'on rencontre nous
avons de longues conversations qui
soient des surveillants dégradés les
directions tout le monde et tous autant
qui sont nous disent que ça n'est plus
possible ça n'est pas possible de les
laisser continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions c'est dangereux pour eux
c'est dangereux pourquoi parce que comme
nous ont dit les études Gradignan les
surveillants y sont violents ici mais
ils nous ont dit de façon très j'ai
trouvé très intelligente et très sensée
il sent violent on s'en prend plein la
figure mais faut les comprendre moi
j'avais jamais entendu ça faut les
comprendre on est trop ils deviennent
dingue il pète les plombs comme nous
parce que évidemment c'est les
surveillants et les détenus c'est des
hommes de 20 de très jeunes
bon assez costaud parfois assez bon qui
sont plein de vie restez enfermés 22h
sur 24 dans sa cellule sans autre
activité que s'énerver ensemble c'est
pas bon et pour les surveillants courir
moi je les ai vus mais dans la coursive
courir toi c'est la parloir toi c'est la
promenade attends non je me suis trompé
toi rentre toi sort toi vers la douche
toi c'est infernal c'est un rythme
infernal et donc il y a d'ailleurs il y
a des violences et je pense pas non plus
que ça fasse partie de la de la
réinsertion de la violence qui vient de
du fait que
voilà ils sont tous finalement ils
subissent le même sort
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai répondu sur les 110
euros par jour à votre question et sur
la réinsertion parce que c'est vraiment
dommage c'est des occasions ratées parce
que il y a aussi des beaux exemples en
prison je pense à au fameux Berthé one
je sais pas si vous le connaissez
c'était un braqueur
qui dans le surveillant rentre dans sa
cellule il lui dit mais Berthet c'est
toi qui dessine ça mais je veux que tu
me dessines tu as de l'ordre dans les
mains Bertin et tous les jours le
surveillant revenait en disant Berthet
tu as fait mon dessin et Berthet se
moquait de lui et puis finalement il a
fait un dessin en décidant de
surveillant à genoux devant lui en
disant Berthet je t'en supplie un dessin
le dessin a fait le tour de la prison
tous les surveillants ont défilé devant
la la cellule de Berthet pour demander
un dessin aujourd'hui Berthet il a signé
avec le Journal de Mickey il est dehors
et il fait des bandes dessinées
sensationnelles sur la prison donc
ça c'est un exemple oui formidable mais
il y en a d'autres bien sûr que tout le
monde ne sort pas en récidivant mais si
on pouvait ajouter ce plus qu'on que la
société doit pour se pris là je trouve
c'est dépasser oui mais
dépasser la vengeance
dépasser la punition ok il y a la
punition mais la dépasser pour pour
apprendre des choses à ces gens les
remèdes dans les rails
d'une société normale
réapprendre à vivre ensemble à vivre
puisque de toute façon ils sortiront
donc c'est un mauvais calcul de ne pas
mettre le paquet sur la réinsertion en
prison
quant aux plats sont extérieures alors
là mille fois d'accord vous savez qu'il
y a un chiffre de 900
placements extérieurs par an en France
qui est absolument un chiffre en dessous
de je trouve en dessous de ce que ça
vraiment on devrait le multiplier le
placement extérieur j'imagine vous savez
tout ce que c'est
il y a les fermes de
d'Emmaüs qui accueillent les sortants de
prison
qui ont des reliquats de peine à
effectuer ils apprennent un métier ils
apprennent à vivre avec d'autres gens et
si ils s'en vont ils sont évadés ils
retournent en prison
et ça arrive ça arrive bon il y en a que
900 parce que elles ont beaucoup de mal
à survivre parce que figurez-vous que
elles sont mal financées par l'État
[Musique]
malheureusement le prix de journée quand
les fournisseurs de ces fermes c'est la
prison c'est l'état c'est les magistrats
etc c'est le Ministre bon
puisqu'on les fournit en prisonnier et
quand leur chambre ne sont pas remplies
elles ne sont pas financées donc ils
payent pour ces chambres qui ne sont pas
financées donc c'est idiot je vous
transmettrai si vous voulez
la note que j'ai reçue de citoyens et
justice sur ce sujet qui est très
intéressant de même que j'ai visité une
ferme de l'espoir dans l'Essonne qui est
un endroit
franchement bien où ils accueillent des
tiges il leur manque 100.000 euros pour
terminer l'année
c'est un peu dommage c'est un peu
dommage qui disparaissent alors que ils
font un boulot extraordinaire c'est une
ferme où il recueille des tas d'animaux
perdus abandonnés qu'on leur confie il y
a de tout comme animaux mais j'étais
passionné j'aurais voulu rester là tout
le temps et et je crois que c'est bête
de voir des endroits qui marchent et qui
et qui périclite faute de
et ça je vous passerai aussi le
que vous alors la Talaudière
et bien nous allons dans nous nous
rendons dans les endroits quand par
routine parce que on se dit tiens il y a
longtemps qu'on n'est pas allé là ou
parce qu'on voit que l'endroit est
surpeuplé et là ou alors quand on reçoit
beaucoup de lettres de signalement et en
ce haut là là il y a un truc qui va pas
on reçoit trop trop d'alerte et c'est
pour ça qu'on est allé à la Talaudière
les constats ne sont pas définitifs donc
ça m'ennuie de vous en faire part mais
je crois que c'est un endroit assez
compliqué
bien que alors la rénovation
moi
j'en avais entendu parler par des
professeurs qui
œuvrent à la Talaudière et qui m'ont dit
c'est atroce pour faire court on ne peut
plus faire court pratiquement parce que
on ne s'entend plus dans la tôle
tellement ça ça fait du bruit mais enfin
bon ce sera utile je voudrais dire que
de toute façon de rénovation il n'y aura
pas tant qu'il y aura tant de monde par
exemple on dépense beaucoup d'argent
on dépense beaucoup d'argent pour la
dératisation la désinfection mais vous
avez déjà eu des cafards chez vous
j'imagine ça est très bien que faut
vider les lieux quelques quelques heures
et là on ne peut pas vider les lieux du
tout donc à peine on a pu chuté les
cafards une fois que il reviennent trois
huit jours après les rats c'est pareil
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris quelque
chose je m'en ouvre à tous les
directeurs que je vois et à tous les
gradés à tous les surveillants pourquoi
on trouve alors vous savez les fenêtres
sont obstruées par des
des cailles beauty dans lesquels les
détenus évidemment
font des trous pour continuer à se
passer des trucs et à jeter des choses
par les fenêtres moi je comprends pas
pourquoi on paye pas ce qu'on appelle
des oxy pour ramasser par terre ça
éviterait les rats jamais compris jamais
compris ça
voilà madame au Bono je pense que j'ai
répondu à vos à vos questions sur les
self en tout cas j'espère
la suppression
de ces instituts je ne sais pas quoi
vous en dire moi j'ai toujours pour
qu'il y ait des instituts qui produisent
de la de la de l'intelligence et des et
des et des statistiques c'est normal
mais cela dit le coût de la rétention
administrative je vous invite à vous
rapporter au
un rapport de l'accord des comptes celui
qui m'a fait sursauter
690 euros jour
alors
ça pose quand même un énorme problème on
en revient donc à l'assignation
résidence au bracelet électronique parce
que là ça va pas du tout c'est et comme
on était avec André ferraille il est
tombé sur ce chiffre en épluchant des
rapports c'est dit enfin c'est pas
possible et donc on a demandé
confirmation spécialement aux deux
conseillères de la Cour des comptes qui
avaient fait le rapport et qui nous
l'ont confirmé donc voilà je vous laisse
vous êtes la représentation nationale
je ne sais pas quoi faire de chiffres
parce que je sais bien qu'il y a un
double tranchant c'est la première fois
que je donne ce chiffre
j'espère vous en ferez bon usage je sais
pas quoi
je ne comprends pas comment ça peut
coûter si cher
oui
c'est un chiffre de la Cour des comptes
dont on a demandé
à demander confirmation
oui
voilà je sais pas quoi vous dire sur la
suppression de ces organismes moi j'aime
pas tellement qu'on supprime des
organismes qui fabriquent qui fabriquent
des des statistiques
c'est dommage parce qu'il y en a pas
assez par exemple je vous parlais par
exemple s'il y a seulement il y avait
une étude sur les gamins qui arrivent
qu'on retrouve dans les centres
éducatifs fermés qui viennent de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et qu'on retrouve
plus tard sur les bancs des comparutions
immédiates
il y a quand même un énorme problème
pourquoi on met pas le paquet pour
réparer ses enfants d'ailleurs ces
enfants je suis d'accord ils n'ont pas
eu de chance au départ donnons-leur la
chance qui leur manque au lieu de les
coller dans des endroits quand vous
lisez les reportages et même les
constats qui sont faits actuellement sur
les foyers de l'enfance ça fait froid
dans le dos aucun nougne enverrait ses
enfants comment Canon ne laisserait ses
enfants être défendus dans les
conditions de la comparution immédiate
pour laquelle nous prenons également une
réforme puisque non seulement ça ne
diminue pas mais ça augmente et c'est
une procédure extrêmement pourvoyeuse de
prison euh où on peut prendre
5 ans que en très peu de temps sans
véritable instruction du dossier
c'est une procédure
au cours de laquelle je dis pas que
c'est pour ça qu'elle est morte pauvre
la paume c'est horrible mais c'est quand
même je sais pas il y a quelque chose de
l'ordre du symbole de voir qu'une
magistrate est morte en présence une
audience de comparution immédiate
j'espère avoir répondu à tout
ah mais non
pas du tout
pas du tout sur la première visite à
Fresnes il y a 5 ans et rien ne bouge je
rappelle écoutez je peux vous souhaiter
un autre exemple tout aussi choquant il
y a 20 ans il y avait ce formidable
rapport prison une humiliation pour la
République et qu'est-ce qui a bougé des
choses ont bougé mais sur la
surpopulation rien ne bouge et
tant qu'on en sera là je pense que bien
sûr ça peut être désespérant de se dire
rien ne bouge des petites choses bougent
quand même
mais c'est vrai que c'est à la malle et
c'est vrai que c'est pas satisfaisant
quand au fait qu'il y a 6 fois plus de
suicide en prison
nous on a une standard
au contrôle général quand on a quelqu'un
au téléphone qui vous dit cette fois
c'est foutu une grosse voix
cave qui lui dit d'être c'est foutu là
je vais m'en en l'air bon on a
d'autres solutions que d'appeler la
prison pour qu'ils aillent très vite
voir ce qui se passe mais après je pense
que quand vous savez Gradignan dans la
coursive il y a un surveillant pour
toute la coursive quand il y en a puis
voyez tous les petits drapeaux vous
savez les drapeaux c'est ces bouts de
papier que les maintenant vous
connaissez tous puisque vous étiez les
prisons qui qui passent à travers la
porte et qu'il s'agite et qui font
de qu'ils entendent pas dans le couloir
et donc tout s'agit de tous ces petits
drapeaux s'agitent pour dire sur parce
qu'il y a pas de boutons d'appel
surveillance vient nous voir mais quand
on l'a agité un nombre de fois énorme
que personne n'est venu parce qu'il y a
personne je pense que on a demandé des
soins on a demandé le dentiste on a dit
j'arrive pas à aller aux toilettes on a
dit je voudrais changer de cellule je
parce que moi je suis une en fumeur mais
connais-tu son fumeurs je voudrais
changer de cellule parce que mon code
est venu me martyrise mais on se sent
totalement abandonné de l'État alors je
ne dis pas que en détention il y a pas
il y a des gens beaucoup plus fragiles
que dehors
s'arrête ça recolle quand même des gens
plus fragiles certainement mais il y a
quand même une forme d'abandon des
pouvoirs publics quand on est là dedans
j'imagine qu'il vous pousse pas à
l'optimisme et à se dire ça ira mieux
demain
et je pense que c'est tu veux ajouter
quelque chose André oui
la question du nombre des suicides pose
aussi celle de la présence des malades
mentaux en prison qui sont on dit mais
là aussi sans statistiques véritable que
70% des détenus prennent un traitement
de la sphère psychiatrique alors dans
les traitements de la sphère
psychiatrique et les traitements de
substitution il y a les antidépresseurs
enfin il y a des petites choses il y a
aussi des antipsychotiques là aussi on
dit mais sans prouver que les problèmes
de psychose touchent entre un carré un
tiers de la population pénale c'est
peut-être beaucoup mais en tout cas un
quart c'est assez simple assez réaliste
et donc il y a un nombre très important
de de malade mentaux qui sont dans les
prisons les uns
parce que faisons l'objet de procédure
correctionnelle ils n'ont pas été
dépisté au stade de la procédure parce
que l'expertise psychiatrique n'est pas
obligatoire en matière correctionnelle
les autres parce que ils ont été
déclarés partiellement irresponsable
mais partiellement responsable et donc
ils ont été condamnés à de la prison
d'autres enfin parce que la prison
une mauvaise influence sur leur santé
mentale mais en tout cas ce sont des
situations devant lesquelles
l'administration pénitentiaire est
démunie sont des détenus qu'elle ne peut
pas traiter qu'elle ne peut pas faire
sortir parce que les suspensions de
peine pour raison médicale en pleine
terre de psychiatrie sont rares ici et
de toute façon un peu impossible
concrètement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
lieu de sortie donc la question des
suicides me semble-t-il et aussi
directement corrélé à ça
bien merci chers collègues je suis donc
la fin de cette audition et je vous
remercie d'être rendu disponible pour
l'édition de la commission des lois
et on se retrouve à 17h pour l'audition
de la mission fonction publique et
transformation de la fonction publique
avec plaisir